[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yo yo yo yo salut à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau live welcome home et
welcome for this new livelad ouais salut
les francophonie yo yo yo ça va tu es en
forme tu es chaud tu es bouillant bon
après le plus que jamais ouais plus que
Jaja plus en forme qui est dans le
aujourd'hui tu es tu as fait plein
d'énergie
quand même avant de partir on vous
partagera quelques petits trucs mais bon
ça a parlé de choses très sérieuse Vlad
d'entrée comme souvent comme souvent dès
le matin alors attention mettre les bons
noms parce qu'on s'est décalé on s'est
décalé de place donc toi tu es Vlad
catchev je mets pas le gemme devant
parce que j'ai envie de dire le titre
appartient dans mon nom
j'allais dire à partir à trop de
personnes pour que c'est possible il
faudrait un autre titre pour toi et du
coup moi je vais enlever le Vlad catchev
et je vais mettre d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant pour moi comme c'est pas
normal peut-être que un grand mot donne
le classement en 2003
personnes c'est intéressant pour moi qui
est le nouveau titre un peu crié aux
échecs pour différencier de télécom des
autres gammes mais en fait moi je pense
qu'il faut juste
il faut garder le titre de Grand Maître
et créer un titre intermédiaire entre
mettre international et grand maître
tu vois tu vois pas enlever le titre de
GM qui ont déjà le titre de jeu tu vas
pas lui rendre
parfois
un tel que moi vlades et je vais faire
je vais faire c'est migrants
[Musique]
le prendrait mal s'il était plus grand
maître
je pense que non ce serait chill non
je m'en doute on lui demande on lui
demande tout à l'heure quand il revient
après après la deuxième pause parce que
il a eu cette discussion en fait depuis
peut-être 25 ans déjà et je parle
entendu une seule belle proposition pour
une routine pour pas une seule personne
mais créatif sur ce sujet personne
normalement moi y compris le problème
c'est qu'ils ont laissé la situation
pourrir pendant une vingtaine trentaine
d'années et tu as l'impression que c'est
difficile de revenir en arrière oui tu
sais pourquoi ça a été fait par l'ancien
président de Luffy il faudra aussi pour
qu'il y a plus de figurations aux échecs
parce que les avais besoin de leur
permettre et c'est comme ça que il est
doublé le nombre le nombre de
fédérations nationales au monde en
allure facile et temps comment dire
c'était politique c'était purement
politique c'était pour que les
fédérations aient plus de grand-mère
pour pouvoir parler au ministère des
Sports et enfin la bureaucratie
habituelle où on change
mais il aurait dû créer à ce moment-là
un autre titre en réalité
ils auraient dû anticiper ils avaient
été très intelligents
pour le fuir un sondage qui dure
quelques jours avec les propositions
avec les propositions parce que je suis
sûr que les gens les gens vont trouver
des belles idées si moi j'arrive pas les
gens vont trouver quoi peut-être pas à
l'espace de 3 jours mais l'espace à
l'espace de trois heures moi l'espace de
3 jours sur donc tu donneras un titre
différent pour des joueurs tels que Ding
liren et des pomyachi évidemment qui
joue des finales de championnats du
monde quand même c'est pas normal alors
premier coup E4 tu nous parlais un petit
peu de 4e pendant le live tu pensais que
c'était je rêve qui le voit jouer E4 et
jouer très agressif pour faire mat mais
je m'en doute il est vrai mais je rêve
que il va donc changer ses habitudes que
il va pas ressortir sa catalane
bah ok si pas E4 si BK
en ce moment là je pense il y a
peut-être vendre système pour les noirs
qui sont tout à fait
c'est c'est même pour un match
tel comme maintenant on peut pas juste
préparer toutes les lignes tu sais pas
laquelle
va être choisi par ton adversaire juste
pas pratique juste pas pratique
en tout cas ils sont en retard
parce que il est déjà 11h02
on voit à la caméra que c'est déjà assis
côté
népo mais Ding est pas là et ça peut
arriver que ça commence en retard
pendant le match
pour le titre tout peut arriver là
tout peut arriver mais c'est étonnant
parce que meding il a dit qu'il sentait
pas bien pendant la partie d'hier que il
avait des feelings
qui lui était remonté dans la tête
pendant la partie qu'il était pas dans
son assiette c'est bizarre le signe ce
niveau de la Franche-Comté parce que
d'habitude pendant de tel match il est
joueur ne parlent jamais de leur j'ai
pas leur mauvais feelings etc parce que
c'est comme ça que comme quoi c'est un
peu trop ouvert enfin il faut pas trop
s'ouvrir c'est très bizarre très bizarre
donner des informations à l'adversaire
d'habitude il faut aussi l'impression
que tu es beaucoup plus brandé que tu es
en fait
je vérifie que ce soit par un bug ou
quoi mais ce que tu sais que les caméras
elles sont pas forcément toujours non si
ça ça bouge
c'est étonnant
ça marche pas très bien après on va pas
se mentir
en anglais ça joue ok bon bah nous c'est
un bug et c'est un bug des caméras c'est
un bug de tout
comment c'est possible que ça joue
ok ça joue c'est parce que il y avait
3e
F3 D5
et H3 d'accord c'est alors le facteur
dont je parlais hier ça y est ça ce
facteur a commencé de jouer sur le
facteur important
de tel truc n'oublions pas il est très
fantaisiste dans ses idées rapports et
pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que en gros en
tant que grand joueur de chèque les
lèvres de Job
donc H3 c'est bien aller à H3 c'est bien
aller à voir pour
mauvaise hivic en quelque sorte parce
que de telles qu'on dit que ne sont pas
capables eux-mêmes de trouver de tels
ok sinon
qu'il peut voter les
raisons pour faire ok premièrement je
suppose il faut bien comprendre déjà il
faut comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe
après ces cinq qu'est-ce qui se passe
après fou 7
qu'est-ce qui se passe après je passe C6
parce que chaque couille assez
intéressant
[Musique]
mais peut-être tu veux mettre le
Cavaillon
tout essaye de faire peut-être dames et
deux quatre vitres même en économisant
du pion sur A3 que sur H3 pour que oui
mais peut-être ça passe quand même
d'ailleurs à toi au quatrième au lieu de
H3 et bien ça c'est connu ouais sinon
de comprendre ce 5 h 5
ok ça donne envie de bouffer sur de 5 à
vrai dire parce que je pense que cette
passion ne favorable au noir il faut
donc il faut faire quelque chose de le
centre et maintenant si le moins que
joue que valide de 5 par exemple et
descends tu veux pas E4 que liés
[Musique]
ça peut jouer donc ici aussi après que
les deux cadres je joue pas pour 4h
après faut 3 le pion sur H3 peut te
servir pour qu'il y aura pas un moment
et puis le pion il est pas si mal placé
ouais donc ces cinq CD et si ed que ce 3
et
ok bon ça ça doit aller pour les Noirs
genre c'est juste une position du jeu
d'échec non moi je pense une position de
chaque mais qui peut-être ne jamais
arriver dans les parties de voir non
bien sûr mais je veux dire par là que ça
peut pas être mieux pour les blancs mais
juste tu joues oh moi je ouais ouais
donc H3 je pense que c'est plutôt
antisocial anti-5 parce que mes potes
tous derniers temps mais à contre
il peut le faire quand même
il peut jouer cette ligne là tu sais
et là ça sert aussi donc
pour expliquer simplement en fait c'est
le pion H3 il coupe le fou il coupe le
fond et il y a des G4 qui traînent
ça j'aime bien parce que j'ai pas aimé
son choix le choix de dire et j'aime
bien son choix maintenant parce que
n'oublions pas ne pas ok c'est un grand
joueur grand joueur mais par sa culture
c'est pas un joueur de Gambie dedans
c'est un joueur de la grande fille de la
grande fier de la grande field et donc
lui poser un nouveau problème sur
l'échiquier c'est cool en général parce
que au niveau des instants il peut être
chez qui quoi et d'ailleurs il faut dire
que
Maxime aussi il a eu du mal dans les
gambidam refusait refusait refuser parce
qu'à accepter ça va mais dans les
gambidames Maxime il a pu un peu
souffrir et c'est des joueurs qui ont le
même style historiquement même s'il
n'est pas est devenu un peu plus
universel ils peuvent quand même
retrouver les mêmes problèmes je me
rappelle que Maxime avait été très mal
dans un gambit d'âme refusé ou quelque
chose ressemblant ou une himeo contre un
mec à 24,50 bah écoute on en est
championnats
j'étais toujours le joueur de l'Est
indien une fois je me suis dit il me
faut préparer un nouvel ouverture bien
sûr je tout de suite choper le Gambie de
m'accepter parce que pour un nouveau
dans ce complexe de ceintures c'est
l'ouverture les plus facile ah mais
c'est vrai que la slave si tu es pas
trop genre de cela enfin même si c'était
genre de slave les plans avec cavalier
moi je joue ça toute ma vie pour avec
les noirs et je dois dire que je suis
très gêné par les plans avec cavalier BD
oui parce que t'as pas le temps de jouer
typique avec des sept sans que cetera et
ça parce que je peux juste expliquer
vite fait et tu me corrigeras genre
admettons des quatre des cinq C4 c'est 6
cavalier F3 cavalier F6 E3 et là en
réalité moi je serai plutôt d'humeur de
jouer aussi ce que F5 parce que j'aime
pas sortir le fou mais quand tu fais E6
cette variante avec cavalier BD elle est
hyper pénible
quand tu as dit cette vérité
en 2016 ça m'a pris trois nuits de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui est plus précis
que valait de deux ou trois ou trois et
je peux réussir à comprendre
j'ai pas réussi comment
elle-même
en tout cas le système sans mettre le
cavalier en C3 me mettant le cavalier en
D2 assez pénible et n'est pas qui a
répondu à la question de H3 en jouant
des Français 4 et finalement c'est
marrant parce qu'on parlait du Gambit
d'un accepté qui était plus facile pour
un joueur comme nepo et c'est pas
étonnant qu'il prenne le Punto alors
maintenant
il y a E3 bien sûr il y a cavaliers
plutôt non
il y a dans ma carte
cavalier de décès d'armes français 4 et
à 6
c'est vrai que peut-être ça les réponses
le plus facile
peut-être les réponses le plus facile
alors dans ce cas là
3 parce que si il y a toujours des idées
soit à 4 bouscis à Bruxelles
soit comme ça
soit peut-être moins de suite au lieu de
la 4e
donc E3 alors après E3 on va voir
sûrement ce 5 mais je n'arrive pas à
transposer dans un gambida m'a accepté
améliorer
un général le Gambie totalement
tu peux par exemple le montrer au
deuxième
en général juste et comme ça elle
transpose parce que ce couler il a il
peut être utilisable d'un point de
sonnerie en fait
par exemple
alors attends j'ai une petite question
quand même genre quand il joue si on
prend admettons tu reprends du pion on
est d'accord pas sûr je veux dire
peut-être
possible aussi possible
aussi que comme hier l'idée de
un impôts de bouffer sur ceci je te
rends ça a été une idée purement
antidique peut-être aujourd'hui c'est
presque sur H3 c'est peut-être une idée
purement
anti-pop en quelque sorte
en quelque sorte parce que ce sont les
deux joueurs qui se ressemblent
on va voir intéressant en tout cas
ils sont
où les mecs
il y a eu tout un débat hier sur sur
Twitter parce que il y a les caméras
dans les salles de repos actuellement et
il y a un débat sur le fait que
ça avait déjà eu lieu dans un autre
tournage je crois que c'était un tournoi
des candidats je veux pas dire de
bêtises ça je suis pas sûr mais en gros
les joueurs avaient protesté contre et
elles avaient été enlevées parce que ça
allait à l'encontre de leur vie privée
et donc on avait une petite discussion
avec Vlad mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font
vraiment dans ces salles de repos qui
est-ce que ça peut être
une activité privée
en train de regarder un écran de quelle
activité la définition de
notre enfant et ça explique peut-être
pourquoi quand il y a les caméras en
salle de repos ils vont plus souvent
vous chiottes
oui mais bon enfin c'est une vraie
question
sinon bien sûr la question de la vie
privée pendant les matchs pour le
courant ensemble en général parce que
quelle vie privée pendant que tu serais
marrant
pourquoi tu filmes
parce qu'il a joué c'est bon rentre dans
on va transposer ouais
moi là
par contre je pense il doit déjà
réfléchir soit assise soit peut-être
c'est pas les peines de joie ici tout de
suite plutôt que le saucisse d'ailleurs
que voici je pense c'est plutôt pratique
alors attention parce qu'il peut y avoir
des pièges
dans le sens où cavalier C6 c'est plus
logique évidemment ouais
et donc peut-être qu'il y a un problème
quelque part avec le H3
tu te fais dribuer quelque part il faut
essayer d'être malin quand même ou pas
du tout
non moins une chose de Claire pour moi
que
moi je refais ici pour éviter les prépas
du mec je refais cavaler ceci
parce que je vois pas dans quel scénario
dans les positions avec le pion isolé le
pion
c'est sûr puisque nous on avait fait
toute la série et le pion il va sur H4
pour voiture
et ici le c'est obligé de
par contre pour cela il faut bien très
bien connaître les finances je suppose
que peut-être c'est pas le cas donné
pour parce que je pense que dans ces
positions dans ce monde répertoire
depuis la jeunesse les positions avec le
pur nasale n'ont presque jamais arrivé
peut-être que la faute c'est qu'on n'est
pas traduit notre série de vidéos en
russe parce que s'il avait vu la série
de vidéos en fait tu sais tout de suite
que H3 n'appartient pas au pion isolés
en fait
c'est pas de bol il la faute c'est ça il
a fait assis voilà déjà faire ça vite
c'est faux ouais c'est une faute et puis
parce que après si je pense pas qu'il va
prendre sur des quatre vides pourtant
bah oui non là maintenant non ah il doit
pas être bien quand même
c'est incroyable quand même ce travail
qu'on avait fait sur le pion isolé j'ai
l'impression que même toi tu as
progressé
avec cette série de vidéos j'ai appris
pas mal de choses je leur ai dit par
exemple avec notre série sur le pire
désolé je suis devenu un bon spécialiste
c'était pas le cas avant d'aller voir un
principal de l'énigme peut-être tu peux
montrer elle était analysée pendant les
vidéos elle était analyser au fond quoi
ces quatre réussissent que l'histoire
foot et les lignes principales
éternelles E3
de 5 disons qu'on va lire 3 c'est 5
petitrouk c'est de
tu peux avoir par transposition
d'ailleurs même dans par des cars je
crois oh oui bien sûr et pas que oui
pendant les préparations de vidéos mais
juste à fond à fond et donc je j'aurais
pu être prêt à jouer ça avec les Noirs
contre qui que ce soit le
soir même
voilà
d'ailleurs je dois vous dire que
d'un côté c'est désagréable pendant les
parties quand vos terrasse est arrivé
avec une grosse grosse nouveauté
tactique vous êtes en train de résoudre
les problèmes tactiques sur l'échiquier
ses chiens c'est hyper chiant c'est bien
sûr mais ce qui est aussi très
désagréable c'est quand dès les premiers
coups vous voyez que le mec dans
l'ouverture il joue pas tout à fait aux
échecs il joue contre toi ouais c'est
chiant ça ah ça comme quoi
tu es sûr que j'ai pas ta 200
2500 de parties dans les bases de
données et tu as l'impression qu'il a
juste tous calmé quoi est-ce que tu as
certainement pas l'impression comme
quelqu'un te vois habillé le mec te voit
nu voilà et j'ai envie de dire on sait
très bien ce qu'il est en train de
regarder
en fait
pas bien mais c'est un peu cette
impression que ça fait
c'est complètement ça ouais
c'est dur c'est dur
allez c'est dur pour néo là c'est pas ce
que tu faisais quand tu jouais contre
moi d'ailleurs quand on entamait des
matchs de Blitz c'était insupportable
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux comme
toujours les à l'époque les championnats
du monde c'était les championnats
jouaient au système KO
et quand tu joues qui compte quelqu'un
nettement milieu quoi c'est que toi tu
as une nuit à se préparer et oui il a
tout un répertoire bien établi tout et
toi tu as pas trop de virturé tu dois
trouver quelque chose qu'est-ce que tu
fais le soir pendant trois quatre heures
TU scans
le mec et tu trouves une petite ligne
qui tu penses bien que Venable compte
[Musique]
tu sais ce qui m'est arrivé une fois
j'entame un match de Bullet contre Baki
de cette gagnant trois points tu gagnes
le 7 j'ai fait une faute j'ai battu Baki
à zéro quoi 3 0 3 0 et Baki me dit à la
fin du match ok match revanche dans deux
semaines et ça y est et ça y est et
c'est parti
et en Bullet il m'a fermé ma scandinave
juste fermer quoi il avait regardé tout
ce que je jouais et à chaque fois il a
joué la paire de fou il a vu que je
jouais ça très mal et à chaque fois il a
eu ses deux [__] de fou et moi le
cavalier le foot casse noir tu sais qui
a été 7 ou des 6 sa structure karaoké et
il m'a joué ça pendant quatre ans et
évidemment il m'a battu genre 3 2 3
facile quoi
même en Bullet il fait ça un tel que
Baki
c'est pour te dire
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux Yahoo à un
moment donné
le meilleur interviews de cramique de
tous les temps oui il a parlé des
anciens champions il n'a jamais fait un
tel bon interview que cette fois-ci et à
un moment donné on l'a dit et kasparo
fait alors pourquoi le plus grand
c'était avant Carson pourquoi le plus
grand alors pourquoi parce que je l'ai
dit bizarrement à ce que les gens
pensent
c'est pas parce que il était le meilleur
tacticien du monde le meilleur stratège
du monde
le meilleur machin c'est tout simplement
parce que il est toujours bossé et
modifier son style plus que tous les
autres
toute sa vie il a souffert des petites
modifications modifications
modifications
comme ça pendant toute la carrière et
après il y a moi il y a quelqu'un qui
m'a demandé dans une interview pourquoi
cramique d'après toi était le plus grand
champion du monde cramique et tu sais ce
que j'ai répondu parce qu'il faisait un
mètre 90
je sais pas c'était juste parce que je
pense que pendant que tu disais ça j'ai
réfléchi à quel était le plus grand
champion du monde juste
parce que
c'est comme ça que je l'ai appelé big
Vlad oui
d'ailleurs
non
mais d'ailleurs tu es pas vexé que
Vladimir et vladyslave ce soit le même
diminutif
je suis vieux que c'est en fait que
parce que c'est chez les Russes personne
n'a pu le dire là en fait non personne
et donc en oxydant tout le monde là
très très bien très très bien surtout
dans les cadence rapide mais il est
incroyable il a vraiment une technique
d'une propreté c'est impressionnant mais
à ma raconté comment le travail parce
que les gens faisaient les stages avec
eux et les gens disent tiens regarde
dans je précise ça ça les ouvertures
symétrique en moins chacun cavalier tour
et d'armes
et comme ça pendant tout le stage et que
crier de télé position asymétrique les
points dans notre peau de plus et vas-y
on joue quoi on trouve les Funès mais
c'est pour ça il est incroyable quand il
a ses positions incroyable je pense que
personne n'a jamais
mais il est incroyable quand il joue des
positions comme ça c'est
incroyable son niveau c'est incroyable
juste il trouve trouve trouve trouve de
ressources mais incroyable et le source
pour mec quoi ressources mais je l'ai vu
en rapide dominer des mecs hyper fort
dans tes trucs comme ça même Carlson a
du mal contre lui dans des telles
positions c'est jamais vu ça en fait bah
parce que il est beau c'est que bosser
toute sa vie en fait il joue un truc
symétrique
bah d'ailleurs une fois je me suis
retrouvé dans ce cauchemar contre mais
j'ai réussi tu en es sorti
est-ce que tu joues encore un petit peu
en partie amicale non non pas du tout
et c'est même pas de lumineux
tu as pas envie des fois de clic non
pour moi les échecs c'était jamais clic
d'ailleurs j'étais toujours mal pour
cliquer de le sens propre et sinon je
sais si je joue maintenant ça va être
terminé même contre un tel que
même quand même
qui commence
regardez
comment dire
et maintenant elle pense
c'est une grosse erreur d'avoir fait
assis
le meilleur joueur du monde pendant
quelques temps
du joueur du monde parce que j'ai senti
mieux que les autres le moment
critiquent les moments critiques c'est
le moment il faut réfléchir pour
traduire
de la finale d'essai j'ai pas maintenant
oui maintenant ça veut dire quoi parce
que il est pas sur son terrain en fait
et maintenant il chiale et maintenant
comme je vous ai dit le concept de
fille chante foot
c'est vrai que j'ai du mal à imaginer
attraper un tel comme Baki avec des
fautes comme à 6
la question de savoir que l'opium sur H3
n'est pas bio pour les pionniers les
questions de la culture assez primaire
en fait ouais primaire
on a mis quand même niveau partir de
c'est quand même pas super fort
pour nous c'est le niveau du chat
et maintenant tu chiales pour un petit
pion en finale
[Rires]
ça y est il est sorti que va laisser 6
et maintenant comme
je viens de voir une autre idée
peut-être jouer quand même que vous
laissez trop avec l'idée cavaliers de 4
peut-être et aussi ça peut être utile
dans certains monde pour éviter quelque
chose en général oui peut-être ça moi je
devrais sûre
peut-être tu presses quoi non mais ça
c'est peut-être déjà un bel avantage
peut-être un bol avantage mais au moins
et puis c'est dans le style de Ding je
pense
que dans les mains de Ding ça c'est très
dur
soit donc c'est ça soit décès maintenant
mais décès ça retranspose pas dans
les finales
ou souvent le cavalier n'est pas top sur
saucisses et les milieux sur
3 c'est quand même moins utile si si si
souvent quand tu fais j'ai pas B3
football
c'est
le parti par exemple pour les comment
s'appelait c'est la partie
c'est les parties Carcassonne ici piano
j'ai envie pour réagir un petit peu à ce
que dit le chat je sais pas ce qui est
dans les mains de Ding en ce moment mais
ça a l'air de faire mal
eh parce que ça peut là ça peut être
gênant pour ne pas
non mais si
leur stratégie dans les ouvertures dans
le mois je prends cette direction là
donc à chaque fois jouer des trucs
random moi j'aime bien ça pour moi
l'intérêt personnel professionnel ça va
énormément augmenter
l'intérêt pour le mois tu sais quoi
c'est logique parce que imagine si tu
prends les stratégies militaires quant à
une armée qui a énormément de moyens
financiers comment tu gagnes guerre
asymétrique
évidemment qui a été gagné comme ça et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs intéressant
parce que c'est une guerre entre
communistes
contre capitaliste tu vois en quelque
sorte
avec la force de tes prépas et tu as
tout analysé au fond et moi je fais des
petits des petits Tournelles
tu frappes à gauche à droite et de
l'autre devient fou parce qu'il a ses
fichiers énormes et tu sais jamais où il
va frapper peut-être très malin en fait
de Ding
on va voir
[Musique]
donc c'est se décoller
il repart
bien sûr il y a une autre question que
il faut allumer quoi si maintenant les
noirs
c'était très très typique en tant que
les choses
le truc c'est que pour l'instant jingle
et de les fichiers dans tous les coups
il va surtout pas partout
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que arrive au
niveau de
35 pour Yann un 53 pour pour moi presque
20 minutes d'avance ça montre quoi il
doit regretter Yann de pas avoir scoré
hier ce qu'il avait vraiment une grosse
occase
voilà d'ailleurs comme malgré
ça sympati Poitiers je considère avant
le match je considère comme un grand
favori qu'est-ce que ce serait bien pour
le match si Ding gagne aujourd'hui parce
que ça va quand même beaucoup égaliser
leur chance pourquoi il y a un grand
favoris parce que il est peut-être le
joueur le moins agréable le moins facile
de jouer contre pour
pour
historiquement juste historiquement
comme quoi
et si par sur ce truc asymétrique je
pense qu'ils peuvent vraiment gêner
il peut rendre Yann fou en fait
le problème avec de tel trucs
asymétrique ce il a fait le B5 il est
pas facile de préparer beaucoup
c'est parce que ça demande quand même
pas mal d'inspiration ouais mais quand
un tel que rapporte dans ton équipe
ça devient plus facile même si tu en as
que quatre ou cinq pour cette partie
c'est déjà beaucoup
bon bien sûr ça suffit ouais t'as pas
besoin d'être plus fantaisiste que ça
donc bois 5 cette fois ici c'est vite
moi je pense plutôt faute mais
moi je pense moi c'était fou de toi
c'était fou B3 et c'est foot D3 moi de
toute manière il fait ça avec l'idée que
je dis des dessins que quatre de toute
façon c'est ordi là
maintenant quand même les questions
est-ce que
le quel est le problème pour les Noirs
si elle est noire prennent sur des
cadres
dès je suppose bon ok il faut bosser
on va juste mettre la petite turbine
pour se donner une idée à 4 à 4
[Musique]
jeunes 7 qu'est-ce que ça donne OK dans
ce cas-là sur ce 5 et après il faut ce 5
de séjour
après A4 par exemple si
il y a
et après
EDF où je sens que
et ça arrive aussi c'est rare c'est rare
c'est l'idée de suite
légendaire accroître
cette idée le transfert
et après
il a peut-être de la chance parce que
c'est des fou B7 A4 tu as pas très envie
de prendre
parce que moi que voler à 4 doit donner
un avantage parce que le poisson et
parce que sinon
direct mais quand même moi déjà il faut
dire surtout les deux sont archistes
archi inconfortable sur le seum donc
utiliser chaque occasion de se casser de
là-bas c'est quelque chose
c'est pire que moi quand je jouais c'est
pire que moi ils peuvent pas intéresser
à chaque fois dans la chambre de
répondre c'est quelque chose après moi
je ferai pareil alors place
mais figure-toi quand même c'est pas si
évident de jouer très bien tandis que tu
marches toujours oh ça y est tout de
suite
est-ce qu'ils font vraiment que marcher
c'est quand même la question qu'on se
pose
ok Dalia 2e partie du match une fois le
mec joue le coup ils vont plus marcher
ils vont courir
mais c'est pour ça les gens m'ont dit
hier ce serait bien d'avoir les caméras
dans les salles de repos mais j'ai peur
de qu'on se fasse ban sur twitch
peut-être par contre ce serait hyper
populaire sur les autres types de je
pense
vous seriez une nouvelle plateforme kick
ou tu peux faire un petit peu ce que tu
veux si on streamait sur qui qu'on
pourrait à mon avis
tu vois cette année
[Rires]
c'est complexe
on les voit
c'est donc ça l'avenir des échecs
le site spécial pour doper les choses en
Lituanie
le Champions Tour où les gens gagnent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus d'argent
que de les tournois
c'est vrai que c'est beau
parallèle dans l'autre sens
il y a bien un championnat du monde en
ce moment mais c'est pas des chèques
je sens que ce match va rester dans les
annales nous écrivent officiel
c'est trop mais c'est vrai que c'est
particulier bon Ding est toujours dans
la prépa ça c'est sûr il continue à
jouer tout tempo et c'est que des coups
logiques et il a l'air de bien connaître
le pire dans cette situation là que tu
es presque sûr d'arriver à -50
et encore dans le type de position que
excellente en fait ça je crois c'était
exceptionnel
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est intéressant ce début
de partie et c'est bien joué de la part
de Ding lyen
pour mettre main pour maintenir c'est la
chose les plus réjouissantes dans cette
dans ce match
un petit peu étonné je m'attendais pas à
ce qui frappe aussi fort avec les pièces
blanches d'entrée Ding
peut-être qu'il a eu du bolding de
commencer avec les Noirs d'ailleurs mais
en fait tu sais ce comment ça peut être
expliqué aussi
ok le joueur légendaire soviétique pour
créer les variantes peut-être la plus
ouf de l'histoire des échecs
et quand on leur demande pourquoi est-ce
que dès l'entrée tu joues cette folie
quoi c'est chaque partie etc il est dit
je suis tellement stressé que je veux
que je veux que les choses chaudes
commencent tout de suite
je me sens tranquille donc peut-être ça
explique alors l'approche
comme ça comme ça dès les premières
parties de Genk par exemple que l'action
commence au moins quand ça joue je suis
quand même moi chez qui que
quand il faut attendre attendre attendre
attendre rappelons-nous demain
on nous demande dans le chat comment ça
se fait que nepo n'était pas prêt contre
H3 tu peux pas être prêt contre tous les
coups de l'univers c'est juste
impossible c'est
[Musique]
ça c'était H3 c'était vraiment pas
possible d'être prêt contre ça
c'est trop
c'est beaucoup trop
bon époque qui continue à réfléchir
il a pas l'air bien
ah ce serait dur pour lui de perdre un
deuxième match de championnat du monde
ah non ça va être la fin dans ce cas-là
je pense que c'est la fin il y a
personne qui a
c'est trop
chaque match pour le titre perdu ou je
sais pas à quoi ça comparé même c'est
peut-être 50
par exemple même ceux qui en ont gagné
un genre contre bodynique et qui ont
reperdu après ils étaient
détruire ah oui
à vrai dire en tant que quelqu'un qui a
souvent joué quand même sur la scène
les matchs importants oui je dois dire
que les chemises stretch comme ça ne
sont pas trop bons pour jouer sur la
scène
il faut faire des trucs beaucoup plus
détendu là ok là bien sûr comme comment
s'appelle comment boétallienne
beaucoup à moi c'est très c'est la faute
là tu préfères le Woody Blitz stream
surtout qu'il existe en XXL
il a pas l'air bien
il aurait été plus confortable
après pour quelqu'un de mince comme Ding
c'est moins gênant
mais ça peut avoir son importance
mais il a grossi
depuis 2 jours
il y a encore beaucoup de coups de prépa
tu penses Ding ou pas
encore ici 3 lignes principales genre 5
sur coup partout il voit avoir quelque
chose partout genre un retour de plus
0,50 ce soir c'est presque sûr ok
minimum
40 et donc base c'est le comment dire
c'est le moment très confortable bien
sûr moi mentalement il faut se préparer
quand ta race avantage de ne pas vous
payer de ne pas de frapper il faut se
préparer déjà de commencer de travailler
parce que le mot l'autre réfléchit
réfléchir réfléchir à un moment donné il
faut que tu sois prêt quand même de
commencer de travailler quoi pour
l'instant oui il travaille pas est-ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est coup franc à
25 mètres dans les pieds d'un tel que
Platini
en quelque sorte
et tu dois déjà te préparer pour
pour marquer
on va voir là on est dans la phase mais
mon pronostic ce qui n'est pas réagir
pas trop bien
ne pourvoir être très cher pendant
encore quelques dix coups et après il va
et après ça dépend de dingue tu sais ce
qui serait marrant c'est que nepoïde là
et qui recommence comme au dernier match
à donner des pièces en Inde la partie 3
je retourne à Moscou et c'est bon
à deux je deviens un streamer
ouais mais regarde ça mais tu sais que
ça peut lui arriver juste de
complètement s'écrouler non c'est
possible d'ailleurs ce que ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est la faute
sur la gueule c'était jamais pas
possible de comprendre il perd il gagne
le smiley
tortues
tantales est-ce que je pense trop ça
s'appelle la mythologie grecque c'est
c'est la faute tu montres trop toi
ou alors c'est dû à autre chose
peut-être qu'on essaye de lui
communiquer le coup
à jouer ici
dans ce type de peau en fait parce que
c'est vrai que vous gagnez de l'espace
sur l'île de dame etc mais après faut
voir quelque part alors
une seule ligne pour avant
je pense que ça doit être ça
[Musique]
il a joué B4
bon c'était le bon coup
là ça va être cavalier 4
quand il sera de nouveau ici mais c'est
pas embêtant de perdre du temps comme ça
pour Ding parce que là je change sur BK
tu sais que c'est cavalier 4 à chaque
fois tu redonnes une ou deux minutes
c'est si anecdotique que ça
pour une telle cadence ça va non mais là
il est revenu vite il est venu jouer
cavalier 4 et il va se barrer non
[Rires]
jouer cavalier 4 et dire à des pots j'ai
pas encore fini j'ai retourne
[Rires]
bouge pas bouge pas si on est encore
pour trois quatre minutes
normalement ça va chez moi
et tu vois ces doigts quand ils
s'enlèvent du cavalier qui colle un
petit peu quand même
[Rires]
c'est trop
il regarde vraiment dans le vide quoi
c'est terrible est-ce que dingo
et encore il a la politesse de s'asseoir
pour jouer oui ce serait beau la
nouvelle méta juste arrive tu es debout
tu notes comme ça tu joues tu parles
quoi moi en fait j'ai un truc à raconter
pour ça
à
je jouais le tournoi de calife pour
jouer le comment s'appelle comment
s'appelait le Grand Prix de
[Musique]
la calife a été énorme tu sais mais
c'est hyper fort hyper fort la première
place a été pris par un grand maître pas
trop connu ici mais une légende de Blitz
à l'Union soviétique donc qui s'appelait
Arbaco
il a gagné seul le tournoi de meilleur
joueur du monde c'était quoi cette
technique il était pas bien dans les
ouvertures donc les joueurs lentement
les ouvertures puis il vous reste jamais
trois quatre minutes pour finir les
parties c'était les californas c'était
rapide et tu sais comment on faisait
contre les murs joueurs du monde il
s'élevait il se et le reste de la partie
il est joué de beaucoup hein c'est
tellement humiliant
é
j'aimerais avoir une telle technique de
ma vie
deux trois coups je reviens
c'est dur pour les pauvre vraiment dans
ma cou quand
tu devrais préparer quand même quelque
chose contre le 4 parce que
ok
je crois qu'il fait n'importe quoi un
contre Carlson les parties il s'est mis
à faire ça réfléchir n'importe comment
généralement il a juste
bah il est pas d'habitude de réfléchir
parce que
[Musique]
toute sa vie il a joué très vite il se
ralentit que récemment en fait
ça y est le jeu que le 5 écoutez
d'après les gueules je dois dire que je
peux réfléchir sur ce coup la gueule du
coup parce que ça touche
talon d'Achille sur B3
ça force cavalier ses cinq ans
donc le coût moto les questions c'est de
comprendre après que les seins
qu'il coiffeur parce que il y a pas mal
de coups
peut-être que le 4
si je me trompe pas peut-être un petit
roc donc quoique le moins probable donc
là
[Musique]
prendre sur ce 5 avec un cheval qui avec
la tour donc
et là je suis sûr au moins j'espère que
c'est toujours les prépas de Ding enfin
c'est sur quoi Kyo donc il va encore
réciter réciter réciter récitée
5 vous prend B4
ça risque d'être après kaolin de 3
x 5 dans ma 5 dame de trois petits rues
ça risque d'être
trois personnes
je perds
qu'on tire une personne
donc ce que tu as dit salaire
intéressant logique non mais c'est pas
ça c'est un autre truc qui va le coup
c'est deux oui ça c'est OK et si disons
B3 il fait fout bien
ou là ouais bien sûr quoi
tu ressemblent
donc
donc c'est cavaliers prend puis on prend
cavalier des 7 fous des deux
cavalier C5
ça c'est une possibilité
à la base
en réalité et si petit
[Musique]
tu comprends tout de suite que c'est
hyper fort
ça c'est horrible en plus n'oubliez pas
quand ça touche la cavalier 17
plus en donc moi
un milliard et demi et pas que
c'est pas mal hein quand même d'ailleurs
en parlant
je dois vous dire que je des échecs
chinois je dois vous dire je t'ai
impressionné quand j'étais dans leur
quartier général de l'effet des et au
même temps ça interdication de chez qui
on appliquant c'est un grand
deux étages et sur chaque chambre il y a
des heures dit des heures des Herbiers
où les gens des niveaux différents on
arrive doivent travailler quoi
c'est tout à fait vous savez comment
j'ai pas
en centre de leur préparation pour les
cosmonautes quoi en fait d'ailleurs
j'étais impressionné disons c'était
carrément si scientifique scientifique
scientifique
ils sont devant des ordis comme ça ils
travaillent ils travaillent ils
travaillent
c'est très très comment s'appelle
une salle de repos
tout ça pour venir assis devant sur un
canapé quoi
c'est une belle table bah moi j'aime pas
de télé grosse table en fait moi j'ai
toujours préféré des tables plus petites
en fait tu te sens un peu perdu dans ces
situations là tu dois être vraiment tu
dois t'habituer pendant des années et
des années déjà sur la scène c'est pas
évident quand
les lumières est trop forte tu étais là
comme ça et puis encore la table comme
ça et tu sais pas
aux grandes tables comme ça ouais moi tu
sais j'en ai chiqué taille 4 taille 5
j'ai des plusieurs tailles des chiquets
ils font un certain temps d'adaptation
il a acheté des tailles 3 il aime bien
je le comprends et quand il vient mardi
prochain normalement il doit nous en
offrir un oh
non mais c'est plus pratique pour jouer
j'ai des pièces officielles d'ailleurs
ici
bakim les a offertes des matchs
Championnat du Monde
c'est un beau cadeau
je me respirer au musée d'échec à Moscou
et quand j'ai vu la table où on joue
deuxième match et premièrement je pense
tu sais j'ai eu des sentiments on peut
passer comme le sanglage quoi
jusqu'au trouver le Sandra
je l'ai vu cette table
là le meilleur match de l'histoire
c'est sympa
après moi j'ai des expliqué que Baki a
touché c'est aussi ça fait aussi cette
impression
mais bon tu es quand même bien un Baki
il a touché
à quelqu'un qui a donné amoureuse et là
elle a fait un petit rond dans la lettre
sur le papier et il a écrit ici j'ai
embrassé
elle a pas dit avec quoi
j'ai l'impression
mais je pense que c'est sous-entendu
on fait quoi est-ce que ce serait pas
l'heure de la pause
donc pendant qu'ils sont assis en plus
il y a le petit sponsor chez sarahma et
tout donc
pause ouais c'est le moment à tout de
suite les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est de retour mesdames et messieurs
et la fin la bonne nouvelle je sais pas
si une bonne nouvelle ou pas voilà mais
il s'est absolument rien passé vu qu'on
est parti
donc counter toutes les explications que
les A5 n'était pas dans les fichiers
par contre je suis toujours très
optimiste puisque
les variantes qu'on a montrées c'est
bien très bien dans le style et du
joueur chinois donc il peut trouver il
peut trouver il y a pas trop
alternatives même je l'ai dit donc il va
trouver c'est bien c'est bien
donc ça veut dire que les Blancs Ding
alors à 1h30 son adversaire une heure
D19
mais l'avantage du temps s'évapore quand
même après la question c'est si
l'utilise son temps Ding pour trouver
les coûts
ça va mais si je joue un mauvais coup
enfin si je joue à côté là c'est terminé
faut pas jouer à côté quoi
déjà les positions très responsables en
fait
parce que pourquoi parce que le conflit
est oublié les blancs
[Musique]
qui vise B3 mais qui peut se virer être
mal aussi ça ouais ça dépendra peut être
très bien ou très mal ça peut devenir un
cavalier complètement enfermé sur la
bande qui rebondit jamais dans la vue en
tout à l'heure quand on regardait des
variantes tous les noirs jouer B3 ça lui
prenait la case il était complètement
coupé une fois les blondes prennent sur
ce 5 faut se sent de cetera donc la
question vitale pour les blancs c'est de
bien sortir le phocéan qui pour
l'instant comme quoi passif nano après
on a vu la solution on n'a pas regardé
ici du tout le coup c'est 6
d'ailleurs qui peut être une option
ok il faut ceci je suppose
maintenant de nouveau il voit quand les
dégâts avec un tempo
peut-être encore
[Musique]
en réalité ah mais c'est pour ça
probablement d'ailleurs qu'il l'a pas
dans le fichier cavalier à 5 c'est
sûrement parce que c'est vraiment un
mauvais coup
bah c'est sûr que c'est pas d'aller
droit parce que d'habitude quand on ne
prépare des gros trucs bien sûr on ne
regarde que trois lignes sinon tu peux
plus
donc ça veut dire que Ding il sait que
là il a 0,405 peut-être
non sourd il le sait mais c'est plus
vraiment comment peut-être qu'il a même
jamais su peut-être que cavaler à 5
c'est juste un coup qui l'a même pas pu
regarder
[Musique]
il est très logique quand même ce coca
tu veux ouvrir ton fou tu veux toucher
de toi tu veux maintenant ça s'éclate
en plus surtout pour quelqu'un comme pot
dans cette partie qui est maniaquement
cherche à éviter les positions avec le
piano le piano
après c'est loin le H3 qui est plus ou
moins nouveau c'est loin du cavalier A5
genre c'est sept coupes plus loin
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a eu tellement
de choses à regarder que c'est pas
certain qu'il est là à ce moment là
encore cette bifurcation si elle est pas
principale
et je vois si je vois bien sur les
vidéos les jeux ne sont toujours pas là
en fait c'est qu'il réfléchit depuis la
salle de repos
il réfléchit pas devant les chiquitiers
d'accord tu sais qui a été le premier
réfléchir
qui opère il opère depuis la salle de
repos d'ailleurs
qui a été le premier à faire ça
d'ailleurs réfléchir pas sur la table
c'était le match très bizarre
par rapport à comment ça tourner c'était
le match
contre spaski en 1977 Belgrade parce que
pendant tout le match parce que ne pas
réfléchir sur l'échiquier mais c'est mis
sur une chaise dans le public non au
fond de la scène quelque part et de là
il est regardé
son cou et le revenu
[Musique]
je dois dire par contre que ça peut être
très très déstabilisant pour le
directeur
je pense à vrai dire je pense ça doit
être mon matériel en fait
après tu sais souvent quand des règles
je vais essayer je tente des trucs en
fait pour que les caméras marche mieux
alors après ça vient pas de nous mais il
y a peut-être des choses à faire pour
ça me ressemble alors à la si je me
trompe pas à la technique du box de
s'entraîner contre l'ombre
pas contre le mort tu joues contre
l'ombre
tu t'es pas contre l'ombre ça peut être
assez terrifiant je dois dire enfin moi
ça m'aurait mis un malaise
parce que comme quoi c'est un peu jeune
je pense ça fait la peur un peu mystique
tu sais pas contre qui tu te bats
c'est interdit de parler à l'adversaire
pendant les parties je pense que ça doit
être interdit de
j'ai pas de notaire jamais sur la table
quoi
il suffit juste de rajouter une règle
il n'y a pas que pas être sur la table
qui devrait être interdit par les
parties Vlad c'est que là mon avis c'est
au bout d'un moment on sait très bien
là c'est toujours su genre tu peux pas
alors ça doit être interdit autant que
le dopage
il y a des gens qui demandent sans arrêt
pourquoi est-ce que les caméras de la
chaîne chaise comme anglaise ne bug pas
bah c'est justement parce qu'ils ont un
accès prioritaire aux images
pour que ça marche pour eux à 100% et
l'accès n'est pas le même mais ne vous
inquiétez pas donnez-moi un centième du
budget de la feed et j'organise un
tournoi où les caméras ne buggent pas
j'ai déjà fait en fait j'ai déjà réalisé
ça j'ai juste besoin de un millième même
peut-être et j'y arrive pas moi je pense
que le problème éternel de les filles de
qui les filles de cherchent toujours
comment dire élargir les géographie de
tournoi de chez mais le problème c'est
que les nouveaux organisateurs qui n'ont
jamais organisé en grand
avance là il eux ils pensent tout ce que
c'est facile ouais
etc et ça y est dès le premier jour ça
part en cause toujours comme ça tu sais
que quand j'organise la backup et là
j'organise la prochaine c'est je sais
pas les gens se rendent pas compte mais
c'est des centaines d'heures de travail
c'est incroyable en fait et même là on
était pas satisfaits il y avait quelques
trucs qu'on avait pas prévu et qu'on va
pouvoir régler pour le prochain
événement mais même en travaillant jour
et nuit en pensant que à ça tu fais
encore des fautes bon imagine si tu
arrives et tu penses que c'est facile
c'est pas facile en fait c'est juste pas
facile
c'est c'est juste dur en fait
parce que diffuser une image en direct à
beaucoup d'ordinateurs simultanément
c'est pas juste poser une caméra et
l'envoyer sur Internet c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça
mais bon l'important c'est déjà qui est
les caméras qui marchent correctement
pour le les commentaires en anglais ça
touche quand même plus de personnes et
c'est le plus important
sinon du point de vue personnel je
comprends que pure des gens ici vont
partager mon point de vue c'est presque
sûr du point de vue personnel je suis
content que le moins cher organisé en
kazakhstaner
14 ans et je suis content que pour les
premières fois de l'histoire de
Kazakhstan il y a un truc du niveau
mondial comme ça qui est organisé je
suis content parce que dans ces cas-là
je suis presque sûr que c'est pas la
dernière fois malgré les fautes qu'il
faut encore
passer ton pays donc
c'est normal
what que tu penses du F6 je trouve que
c'est un peu modeste voilà ce que je
pense parce que d'après mon expérience
analytique après cavaliers le plus
souvent c'est bon
parlant de ton match contre
ça a été le pseudo du joueur indienne
avec Krishna et ça pas très bien fini
pour lui tu sais qui m'a rebloqué encore
[Musique]
que quelqu'un
sur le tableau facilement le drapeau
russe chinois je pense ne peut jouer
avec un drapeau neutre non drapeau de
Luffy je pense donc je pense pas que sur
le drapeau russe en fait
en tout cas ça aurait fait il réfléchit
pas assez le moment critique là mais bon
c'est sûr qu'il va le jouer c'est après
qui réfléchit
d'un côté c'est bien que il réfléchit
parce qu'il comprend que c'est le
momentum d'un côté c'est pas mal
oh là là
j'aime pas
que vous le connaissez c'est
comme quoi la plus grande dette jaune de
la musique kazak maintenant parce que
oui il est crié il lui fait de le style
des meilleurs vedettes de qualité
qui a fait le concert de la cérémonie
d'ouverture
[Musique]
une actrice casaque non qui est connue
celle que
rencontre qui a fait un film un peu
érotique
oui je pense qu'il est connu mais plutôt
de les cercles de cinéastes oui mais je
dirais elle est un peu connue elle est
un peu canon parce que le film comme
quoi a fait les autres
je me rappelle plus d'ailleurs du titre
avec Mokhtar le film non non
filles il était très content etc
bon ben écoute on a on attend là depuis
un moment mais c'est sûr que c'est
caille prend C5 après c'est tellement
sûr c'est qu'elle prend ses cinq qui
pourraient jouer cavalier prend fou
prend puis on prend et réfléchir au coup
d'après
pour l'instant ça veut dire que pour
l'instant il voit pas les recettes
claires après cavalier de 7 mais est-ce
que je suis en train de me demander ce
que vous prend F3 ça peut être un coup
ici mais il y a déjà dans notre parce
que tu peux pas faire tu peux pas
prendre et sinon ok pour l'instant ton
four sur Sam et limite et limité mais
c'est pas éternel sinon tu arrêtes de
fou quand même donc
pas pour ici parce que ça force pas GF
déjà
écoutez maintenant donc comment dire en
assiste un moment très important pour
l'issue du mois en fait très important
en équipe elle est bonne frappe ou pas
parce que je pense s'il va faire les
votes choisir la bonne ligne je vous
donne 70% qui ont il frappe
70 ans parce que les pauses qui ont
analysé avec toi sont tellement
confortables avec les bons que moi par
exemple j'aurais été très optimiste
contre qui que ce soit ok sauf peut-être
les autres
il est vraiment nul en fait
il est nul pas possible ah c'est
terrible mais alors attends il y a
peut-être quelque chose mais c'est
tellement perspective
les positions exposées de la dame mais
très de style de
style
attends il peut peut-être même la perdre
pourquoi elle joue quoi c'est terrible
un coup à la sortie de la prépa et ça y
est
le coup est aussi mauvais que les
caméras
c'est terrible ce coup
un coup le premier coup qui joue de la
partie et c'est déjà la faute
à quoi ça leur sert d'avoir deux heures
finalement
pour faire le coup tu as pas envie de
faire quoi ça y est ça y est ça y est
regardez regardez mais pour a compris ce
que
tu es arrivé tout doucement ça y est
tout de suite le corporel se changer
tout doucement il est recommencé
je crois que ça le torturé qui est
français 5 c'est plus logique en plus
j'ai toujours su qu'il était nul furieux
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il est sérieux de jouer à
match de championnat du monde contre moi
avec des tels coups de cavaliers pour un
M6 là il est très heureux de nouveau il
y a des choses qui changent jamais de le
monde quoi
est-ce que je peux déjà jouer le lien
avec les noirs
pas d'ailleurs je suis presque sûr que
si Andrea
je suis sur
des dangereux
mais dis-moi juste comment tu me punis
si je prends sur deux je voudrais savoir
faut que je sens que
ça paraît très dangereux bien sûr mais
comment tu me pries
avec quoi
il est parti courir il a pris deux mais
c'est énorme
bon par contre le seul bon côté de ce
qui revient d'arriver c'est que
stratégie stratégiquement les positions
c'est compliqué encore plus parce que GF
ce veut dire que ok
comment dire aujourd'hui ce matin avec
qui on a parlé de César donc comme César
Adil est jeter les dés sont ajoutés donc
les Noirs
donc les Noirs ont leurs atouts les bois
ont les leurs donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que le roi noir est nettement
plus faible parce que par contre la
colonne j'ai pu se virer intéressantes
pour l'activité de la tour puis donc il
y a un petit bordel sur
l'île de dames en gros
maintenant le conflit
s'aggrava encore en fait c'est pas quand
il a traversé le Rubicon qu'il a dit ça
je pensais que c'est quand il y avait
traversé le rugby
[Musique]
il a dit dans quel
c'est juste avant de le traverser oui
bon c'est juste avant le oui mais bon
[Musique]
combien de mètres avant
ah oui non si
bien sûr c'est
écoutez je dois vous dire que ça me met
trop flatté mais l'histoire
l'histoire
pour moi c'est souvent un peu comme
mardi marché
disons le traversant mais après je pense
que c'est romancé il a pas dû le dire on
traversant quoi mais c'est sûrement
quand les biographes
et c'est écrit comme ça
mais c'est une belle phrase
ça veut dire que ça y est je meurs je
deviens avant ou je gagne après je suis
tué par Brutus
le sort en est jeté ils disent pas le DX
le sors mais en français je pense que
son traduit ça par les dés en son je
t'aime
mais j'ai dit comment ça se dit en russe
si tu veux donc
je parle pas donc moi j'avais les deux
aussi mais bon de toute façon ça veut
dire la même chose
alors maintenant
bah il y a que beaucoup qui peuvent être
fait
soit tu bouffes soit tu joues au cadre
après E4
ça se complique encore plus parce que le
noir peut jouer à ce 4
et faut deux tu peux pas
et si tu vois sur l'autre diagamale le
fou peut être affirmé pendant longtemps
à un moment tu peux te retrouver avec ce
truc sale des Espagnols donc
[Musique]
[Rires]
et en plus le problème c'est que après
ces quatre éléments
il va se faire transpercer partout
enfin partout bah surtout André gardant
les voiles de dire
mais C4 dans ce cadre presque sûr c'est
presque sûr c'est presque sûr
pro E4 ou bien il y a cavalier B3
et maintenant pour un coup
dans cette danse pour jouer 8 B3 et
après encore j'ai pas d'imbécis
il y a peut-être quatre alternatives
j'aime bien
ce que c'est un coup que tu es sûr que
tu vas jouer oui mais pour l'instant ça
attaque rien par contre je suppose
donc moi je répondrais plutôt à dams 7
ou dans Rock je sais pas lequel de deux
je sais d'accord je comprends ce que tu
veux et moi j'aurais pensé de base à
torget 8 pour pas décider la case de la
dame et attendre un coup blanc
aujourd'hui mes amis
il y aura pas de nul il y aura déjà il y
a pas de nul en fait aujourd'hui
quelqu'un doit gagner pour l'instant ne
pouvait favoris mais comme les dosses
jouent pas le meilleur niveau encore
passe pas trop clair mais déjà c'est une
mauvaise opération pour Ding parce qu'on
en a parlé hier avec Fab avec les Blancs
l'objectif ce genre de position avec
deux résultats et c'est ce qu'il avait
jusqu'à maintenant et là il est passé
dans une position à trois résultats
et ça c'est pas une bonne chose pour
Ding c'est que là c'est pas que c'est
pas que en fait comment dire ce que je
sais pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
c'est pas tout à fait qu'il faut crier
les pauses à deux résultats c'est plutôt
que il faut crier des positions
concernées pour
attaquer le roi
mais ici après Jeanne C4 dans ce cette
grande route à vrai dire je vois pas
trop comment attaquer sur ce je vois pas
juste les bandelettes et c'est ça le
problème
c'est ça ce que vous ne pouvez pas dans
ce que je vois
en tout cas pour un match de championnat
du monde très franchement le début de
match en dehors des prépas c'est
oui c'est pas terrible quand même en
dehors des prépas c'est pas terrible ce
que rater le fou c'est ça le C5 à 5
machin là encore cavaler prend F6
évidemment il joue très très bien ils
honnêtement mieux que nous mais pour un
match Championnat du Monde c'est quand
même pas
bah il en manque un quoi il te manque
une seule personne et
ça fait une différence
pour le titre que de toute manière
appartient pas à vous quoi
gagner mais qui voit le considérer comme
champion du monde ça me fait penser à
une punch de Voltec qui a sorti un truc
je me rappelle plus du début de la
phrase mais en gros il dit que c'est le
boss du Game et dire je vais pas me
faire remplacer par le premier connard
qui passe et peut-être que les deux ont
cette impression parce que nepo il s'est
fait juste
défoncé par Carlsen donc enfin ok tu
seras jamais champion du monde pour qui
que ce soit et quand Ding il a même pas
gagné les candidats donc dans un cas ou
dans l'autre en fait
peut-être c'est impression de pas être
là où tu dois être c'est intéressant ça
peut jouer
à un moment donné
en vrai prétendant pour le titre va
arriver en vrai quoi un nouveau que j'ai
pas casse pas est-ce que le Carlson va
revenir de l'ombre et quand même être
encore de jouer le match parce que je
suis passionnant mais ce serait beau
qu'un tel que casse-par of jeune
revienne enfin arrive du coup avec le
même charisme la même énergie il joue à
match contre népot Ding et tu sais la
conférence de presse c'est lui le
champion du monde
je pense qu'un quelqu'un avec le
caractère de kaspard of jeune pourrait
sortir une telle punch mais c'est ça le
match championnat du monde
j'ai cru que c'était un warm up boy
mais c'est vrai que c'est peut-être
l'impression que ça donne ta raison je
trouve que tu as bien
tu as peut-être compris le fond du
problème c'est peut-être difficile
pour se battre contre quelque chose qui
de toute façon on va pas t'appartenir tu
es un usur bâtard
[Musique]
non mais c'est vrai et c'est la
sensation que ça donne au début de match
nous t'es en train de voler quoi pas
vraiment voler mais ouais c'est pas
c'est vrai que là quand tu vois le début
de match pour le moment
c'est ouais c'est dur quoi il
réussissent pas à répondre
au défi
d'ailleurs mes amis que 13 coups joués
chacun a dépassé pas loin d'honneur je
suppose aujourd'hui on va voir le
bonsaïque quand même ça va être sympa
ouais
c'est comme si c'était un match pour la
deuxième place
moi j'aurais perdu que 7,5 contre 45 toi
tu aurais pris 7 et demi quatre et demi
donc il a fait C4 bien sûr ce 4 bien sûr
pour ce dos maintenant
ok je dis déjà à mon avis dans ce site
bon après tout peut arriver dans cette
partie
ici ma position est pas claire
en fait ce gif dans ce type de potion
n'est jamais excellent en fait même
quand à l'époque les ordinateurs
donnaient un bon avantage au bois en
après j'ai toujours sur
qui fait jouer avec le fou B7 et la
colonne j'ai ouverte ça a toujours été
un kiff pour moi pas déjà le problème
c'est que le pion je se sur M6 bien sûr
affaiblit le roi parce qu'il peut qu'on
peut pas se requier
sur juif moi
ça peut être
5 le pion
[Musique]
si tu es arrivé avec le temps mais même
fouder 6 rock roche8 est or G8 c'est pas
si clair
le bon truc avec le pion sur M6 c'est
que en quelque sorte tu es pas obligé de
développer ton fou et fuite
t'es pas obligé parce que d'habitude tu
bouges t'en fous pour lier les tours
pour le reste de la partie
il y a aussi des scénarios tu fais F5 tu
mines et tu mets après le fongé 7 ici et
surtout ici l'autre fait pas gaffe c'est
pas dame ce 7 grands
sur jeu 8 c'est déjà que ça peut être
mat très très vite
[Musique]
et aussi un truc chiant chien chien
chien pour les blondes se positionner
c'est que maintenant après faut se dose
sur chaque coup sur chaque coup il
faudra faire gaffe il va faire B3 ou
cavalier
de à chaque fois que c'est trop possible
et puis à un moment donné vous pouvez
l'une de ses possibilités quand même
truc bizarre est-ce que je peux faire
ici D5
[Musique]
en fait je voulais essayer de caler ça
non non je voudrais en route
parce que si j'arrive à bloquer mais bon
j'arrive pas du tout
mesdames c'est ça ça a l'air fort
ok le bon côté avec dans ce 7 et pas sur
B60
le problème c'est que la dame sur ce
site qu'on croit regarde le papier blanc
ouais c'est ça en fait le plus important
comme quoi comme un poste peu importe
qui avec le noir ici va inspirer un beau
jour vraiment sur judo
c'est c'est naturel quoi
les tarifs mais en fait je vois pas de
plan pour les blancs facile non mais bon
qu'est-ce que je dois faire elle doit
jouer j'ai pas d'âme de fou toi
et puis espérer j'ai pas cavaler de dos
tout ça en toucher ces quatre d'accord
admettons que je fasse B3 à ce moment-là
ok football et puis je peux je veux
tout simple
quelque chose de ce genre enfin
juridique comme ça et si je réfléchis
pas trop il est bien possible que ici
c'est déjà mal pour le bon
pour les noirs
c'est fou B4 mais c'est pas le coup le
plus dur pour éviter fou des deux
j'imagine cavalier des deux
bon c'est -2 sur l'ordi mais ça
ressemble pas à -2 évidemment ça c'est
pas si catastrophique visuellement
mais le problème c'est que si on réussit
pas à attaquer la dame avec les Blancs
c'est fin ok tu commences pas à l'heure
avec dames peut-être de connecter
[Musique]
ou fou de deux je sais pas lequel avec
vous de dos je touche quand même le
cheval je vais peut-être dame en je sais
pas d'abord je suppose ça c'est bien
joué avec les blancs en l'air d'ailleurs
je veux damodo 5 dans Secret
donc tu commences pas avec damodo
si le mec te fait grand rock tu fais
torcer un stand comme ça sur B3 tu as
fout bien et la tour est passée et si
j'oublie trois tu fais fou B1 et là donc
pour l'ordi c'est très important de
commencer par fubé 4
qui est logique qui logique en fait
trouvable mais fous des deux quand même
et maintenant d'un B6
mais on n'est pas les seuls
on n'est pas les seuls ça on n'a pas
compris mais lui non plus
parce que damsat était beaucoup plus
logique si tu rentres pas dans la
profondeur
ça veut dire que
quand tu obtiens un bon pose après avoir
une pause moyenne
à part des plans actifs il faut toujours
quand même pas oublier le préfixes c'est
l'auteur aussi quand même mais tu sais
ce que j'aime bien c'est que hier pour
ne pas le coup le plus logique c'était
fou c'est ça il faut prendre à 5 et il a
voulu être malin et il a fait fout des
six qui était une faute et là
aujourd'hui c'est dames c'est 7 le coup
évident mais c'est le bon coup c'était
dame B6 plus fin et là il s'est encore
trompé mais en fait c'est vraiment non
moi ok c'est sûr
c'est pas son côté le plus fort
en général et à la forme du compte d'un
bout 6
pareil être le coup non plus actif en
fait c'est le coût plus prophylactique
dans ce sens
à chaque fois c'est comme si tu jettes
un dé c'est un peu comme le Rubicon tu
joues ta dame aller à Jacques et comme
ça pendant toute la vie c'est un joueur
de chez eux en fait tu fais que jeter
des dés
bah je pense que c'est les philosophes
grecs qui ont souvent comparé la vie au
jour de déco
c'est logique en quelque sorte on sait
jamais de toute manière c'est pas toi
qui décide c'est les dieux
le hasard
parce que
peut-être ceux qui s'enlève beaucoup de
charge mentale
en faisant confiance au hasard
avant quand tu prends des décisions de
toute façon tu peux jamais savoir alors
autant jeter des dés
d'ailleurs n'oublions pas historiquement
quand les échecs on ne t'écris encore
sous la forme du jour qui s'appelait
château rengar chatteranga
c'est peut-être en réalité plus logique
note
d'ailleurs juste en parle jamais de la
politique juste une petite une petite
métaphore que je trouvais récemment
souvent souvent souvent souvent souvent
des jeux plus depuis combien de temps
eux ils comparent les géopolitique
machin avec le jour de chèque en fait
c'est faux c'est la faute il faut
comparer le jour le géopolitique avec le
jour de tutoranga
quand il y a pas de contre
cette idée il y a une semaine
c'est logique
ça
ah mais c'est peut-être pour ça que les
caméras sont cryptées comme ça ce qui
réfléchit souvent depuis la salle de
repos
ils ont peur voilà il va jouer non il
est revenu sur l'échiquier il va jouer
rapidement
regarde parce que le bus niska n'a
toujours aussi que les effectifs
[Musique]
beaucoup énormément d'infrastructures
pour qu'on prenne le train contre toi
peut-être
les mesures individuelles de ce
on attend le coup
mais là il faut comprendre l'idée du
fouet 3 fous des deux et c'est pour ça
maintenant je comprends un postérieux
que leur dit propose même un coup comme
dame un
pour grand rock ou des deux
d'ailleurs je dois dire que si tu es un
fort joueur et tu réfléchis ici tu peux
trouver d'abord Damien tu peux tu peux
c'est pas un coup fantasme il a fait
et il commence par fouder deux
ça va
ok ce qui peut arriver alors
est-ce que j'ai mal à comprendre c'est
quel est ton plan avec les Blancs parce
que les Noirs c'est clair ce qu'ils vont
jouer enfin ils vont venir taper ici et
faire F5 avec les Blancs j'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est quoi notre plan tu te
vois essayer de toucher ce 4 tu joues
trois que vous les deux faut boire dans
mon dos a priori et comme quoi tu
montres que sa belle formation sur l'île
de dames fragile elle est
c'est un peu un château de cartes ouais
donc
chose que peut-être si le noir sont très
efficaces ça va jamais marcher mais
c'est le point général ils ont il faut
quand même viser ces quatre quand même
n'oublions pas la ligne s'est mis
ouverte noir contre les calommes le roi
blanc c'est le collongé et pour les
bancs c'est vrai
ça va quand même être mieux pour les
noirs
le
problème maintenant pour les deux je
pense qu'une ni l'un ni l'autre pendant
le deuxième partie du match n'est pas
encore prêt pour une bagarre de rue
avec les deux ont envie de faire nul
dans cette position que les deux
seraient contents de pouvoir stopper la
partie et prendre nul je comprends ce
que tu veux dire ouais c'est trop trop
dans le match confortable
dans la chambre de repos dans notre côté
quand il reste 12 parties derrière donc
tu as quand même le la marge pour
remonter
vous voyez elle est très heureux avec le
noir oui bien sûr toujours très heureux
il y a beaucoup de monde qui aura avec
les Noirs quand même ici
bah moi au plaisir par exemple
[Musique]
on a toujours un biais cognitif quand
les Noirs ont plus que ont égalisé un
tout petit peu plus tu as l'impression
que noirs sont vraiment bien alors que
c'est pas le cas parce que tu dois pas
avoir une telle position après 15 fois
avec les autres d'ailleurs l'exercice
mental
très typique pour par exemple les noirs
sont sortis de l'ouverture avec un bon
pose donc les Noirs pensent que c'est
c'est à leur milieu pour les Noirs
mais
c'est quelque chose de connu genre si tu
analyses je crois pas qu'on puisse se
faire avec chaise comment
du coup comme ça
la t'aurais jamais fait à 3
[Musique]
mais tu aurais jamais fait à trois
c'est juste ça paraît stupide mais parce
que tu as les blancs et
si je suis généralement plus ambitieux
que ça mais oui comme ça perdu un temps
tu c'est marrant
donc là c'est un petit peu ce qui se
passe je pense pour nous aussi c'est que
c'est tellement tu as tellement égalisé
avec les noirs
que tu as l'impression qu'ils sont déjà
nettement mieux alors que ça doit juste
être proche d'égalité
il faut dire qu'à moyen que malgré que
objectivement par l'homme mais pour ne
pas du tout on n'a pas du tout
impressionné de l'ouverture de cette
partie quand même avec ce coup les
Besançon
on peut dire qui est-ce qu'il sent bien
quand même dingue mais c'est vrai il
trouve sur l'échiquier
pour le mec et la voiture c'est souvent
il le sent quoi c'est
pour ça qu'il a un aussi bon score
contre lui tout simplement c'est qui il
comprend ses réflexes c'est naturel pour
eux ils comprennent ce qu'il a compris
c'est juste un très mauvais match up
pour
pour Ding mais ça peut changer il suffit
Ding en gagne une et ça peut changer
toute la dynamique
pas n'oublions pas
à l’équipe
de manière très convaincante les gens
moins boitier une seule fois avant
jamais et en plus que pendant qu'elle
était considéré comme
il est bien écrasé aussi pareil donc
c'est faisable moi il faut un déclic
ouais il faut un déclic bah Fischer il
avait créé de toute pièce le déclic
c'était aussi
c'était aussi l'histoire de des parties
d'hôtel
[Musique]
depuis qu'il a commencé à le battre
c'est plus du tout le même scénario
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est sûr que c'est Damien
le coup plus ou moins c'est quand même
trop logique ça protège E4 ça tape B4 ça
fait trop de choses dame de toute façon
tu dois faire quelque chose quoi
aussi un coup plutôt qui n'est pas dans
l'esprit de la pause mais normalement
pour un être humain
juste pour ne plus haut penser à ça
on va essayer d'éviter non c'est vrai
que comme dit l'expression
connue
la plupart des parties
perdues avec les rock opposés ça a été
parce que les grands n'ont pas joué en
jouet roi Bamba au bon moment trop tôt
ça veut dire
les rock opposés il faut toujours éviter
de jouer un coup de défense inutile et
là on sait pas si on va chantera utile
ou pas donc moi je suis toujours
d'humeur de retarder le plus longtemps
possible
dans toute manière comme je joue toute
ma vie
et j'adore cette ouverture toujours je
peux vous dire que quand les positions
se compliquent en cours de trop pour le
noir
roi suite ou un fou de 7 et ça peut
devenir juste moine - 3 quoi ça peut ça
peut être le prix le prix de chaque coup
est très très élevé
d'un côté c'est dur de l'autre côté se
faisant ce que j'aime bien c'est que ça
défend et ça attaque d'ailleurs j'ai
petite phrase de raconter je sais pas si
tu es
pas un joueur de liste
et dans son livre il a écrit quand
est-ce que je joue le standing je joue
le dire quand je me sens pas bien parce
que je sais que chaque coup est très
important et c'est un moyen pour moi de
me chauffer
c'est la logique à l'envers
[Musique]
ais vraiment d'humeur de le retarder ce
coup
mais dame en plus il y a vraiment pas de
F5 D5 parce que tu prends tu refais
chaque quoi
n'existe pas dans ce cas-là bien sûr le
calculer est-ce qu'on a montré
non mais c'est sûr que c'est ça
rembobine
et là on sait pas mais comme l'ordi
donne F4 en premier comme meilleure
compense the F4 mais ça peut aussi être
juste EDF qui vient d'ailleurs
intéressant est-ce que sans parler à moi
ou à mortaz avant tu as entendu cette
expression le prix d'un coup je sais
non voilà donc hier par exemple j'ai
écouté un petit peu les commentaires de
guéri et comme c'est quelqu'un de
ressent oui il utilise aussi très très
souvent cette expression qui existe
l'expression jouer un coup
ce que tu prendrais les blonds ou les
Noirs dans cette position dans cette
position
je sais pas j'aurais pu vous faire jouer
à ça avec les bons et avec le noir non
je suis pas 10 goûté ni parents contenu
par l'autre
un peu perdre ça avec les deux couleurs
et d'ailleurs facilement
n'oublions pas Ding c'est un joueur
quand même très très
concret et qui adore les bagarres
directs en fait parce que c'est un très
bon calculateur déjà et ça veut dire que
comment dire
même si objectivement a peut-être un peu
moins bien non je sais pas quoi c'est
son jour
ça convient au style de peau et ça
convient au style de aussi en fait les
deux sont dans le même dans leur
facteurs
aussi possible
ça veut dire que sur Grand qui veut pas
dameurs
mais peut-être bien de
déjà en jouant un tours
il garde les possibilités il a gardé les
possibilités de rencontrer F5 avec eux
pour F5
d'un coup
compliqué
donc sinon
au niveau du temps plus ou moins pareil
pour le 2 donc
pour Ding
et
pourtant maintenant à partir de il y a
quelques temps chaque outre est
responsable
tu peux perdre la partie en un coup
quand est-ce que tu faisais
j'ai pu commencer
bravo grand rock là quand même c'était
le coup le plus évident
depuis tout à l'heure
c'est un coup facile
[Musique]
c'est complexe comme position
je pense
je peux dire que le meilleur joueur de
tel type de tel type de position de tout
le temps c'est bien sûr Gary
il aurait été incroyable
il aurait senti
personne par exemple a dit que
un joueur qui a calculé autant de
variantes dans les positions compliquées
c'était c'était sa vie les positions
comme ça
t'imagines comment il aurait atomisé
Karpov dans une telle position
votre temps au rugby
scublé en fait je vais pas chercher à
faire les records du monde tout ce que
je fais trois fois le truc et je veux ça
à côté mon frère par exemple après
quelques exercices réussi à faire le
truc
son meilleur temps c'est déjà la 45
c'est pas très intéressant
bref ici de pendant le Fuge pendant le
festival de joue j'ai vu leur compet eux
ils font ça au moins devant ce compte
du monde
moi j'aime pas trop les jeux quand il y
a pas d'adversaire
j'aime pas trop jouer à des jeux lorsque
j'ai pas d'adversaire
comme
bon là c'est le temps ton adversaire
mais j'aime moins
alors en tout cas nepo il reste beaucoup
plus assis regardez il est encore là
présent à table
je pense c'est tout simplement parce que
il se sent beaucoup mieux que tout à
l'heure il est moins stressé que avant
et il y a donc moins de besoin de alors
se promener comme ça toujours je pense
il se trouve à l'aise il faut bosser
maintenant on n'a pas on en a pas parlé
mais il avait une demi-heure d'avance
quasiment à la sortie de l'ouverture et
il a déjà 7 8 minutes de retard
il a pas bien joué Ding
UE je suis complètement sûr qu'il y aura
encore pas mal de
des os et des bras pendant cette partie
là et Maxime qui nous écrit pour une
époque je pense que simplement voir Ding
qui a l'air autant paralysé ça donne la
méga confiance c'est vrai que dingue il
dégage pas non plus dans son interview
d'hier de dire qu'il arrive pas à jouer
parce qu'il a trop de pression c'est
juste incroyable tu dois jamais dire ça
c'est comme de prévenir à ta copine bien
en avance que tu es impuissant quoi
j'ai pas cette expérience là
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup trop mais c'est vrai
probablement c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
tu sais ce soir je vais pas réussir mais
demain non plus
[Rires]
une journée normale quoi
c'est dur
c'est dur là pour dingue s'il la paire
il peut complètement imploser Ding
est-ce que dans salle de pause il est
sale Ding ou peut-il consulter un coach
non il est seul mais il y a des caméras
donc il peut il y a des choses qui peut
pas se permettre et c'est vrai que
peut-être pour faire baisser la tension
là il aurait besoin non pardon je dis il
est en salle de repos il est seul mais
il y a des caméras et puis alors que
pour faire baisser la tension il aurait
peut-être besoin de solitude
c'est le fa qui est en train d'arriver
Ding a plutôt un bon mental en cas de
défaite après en match on sait jamais
mais il y a un monde où il se libère
ensuite
ouais ouais non non on sait pas en fait
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que il
est pas si
ce que moi
les jokes juste comme sérieusement dans
la salle de choses sales quoi il est
assis ou il se peut
mais bon
[Rires]
j'ai pas blagué depuis tout à l'heure
mais j'étais chez moi aussi sur YouTube
je sais pas trop de quoi tu parles quoi
c'est complexe on affable qui est en
train de faire son arrivée fracassante
ouais ben c'est mais plus que 50 minutes
pour le coup c'est bizarre d'avoir
que c'était un carrefour et mais c'était
vraiment une grosse faute
bah je pense qu'il peut être expliqué
par un truc très simple en fait
je vois je viens de voir cette tu peux
me dire les premiers coups et moi je non
ce créateur non ce 4 enfin Descartes
E3 eo6 que veut dire 3 que valait de
cette fou de toi
mais en classique là tu arrives souvent
à de telles positions avec les Juifs
mais le problème c'est que Ding il n'a
jamais rentré dans cette variante là il
est toujours joué comme livre 3 E3
c'est juste dans son cas
permet au noir de jouer juif c'est juste
le manque de culture en fait
il a jamais su
il a jamais entamé des mérons
au quatrième ou peut-être que les trois
que les trois il faut que je sente
peut-être mais pas les miens
qui connaît pas le pion isolé l'autre il
connaît pas la slave
après tout vieux
il nous faut
enregistrer une note longue série des
vidéos pour les candidats quoi
[Rires]
pour 1500 mots pour les candidats
exclusivement et on pourrait la vendre à
la feed pour améliorer la qualité des
matchs
juste qui les offre quoi aujourd'hui
mais après faudra être sûr qu'il regarde
non il faut obliger de regarder par le
contrat
pour être vraiment sûr
est-ce que tu veux est-ce que tu veux
faire un petit changement peut-être Fab
qui te remplace tu fais une petite pause
oui yo yo yo peut-être je vous retrouve
tout à l'heure
au boulot
ce qu'on a fait le touret on a déjà fait
le tour avec avec vague on va faire le
tour avec Fab et puis après du coup
qui arrive on fait des tours
[Musique]
j'ai pas trop cherché à comprendre quoi
bah écoute
nous non plus
on va s'installer tranquille
le F le F ça va le cas ça va ça va tu as
mis le kimono
[Rires]
salut le F
il fait n'importe quoi en fait non mais
le moment décisif de la partie enfin le
moment critique de la partie pour le
moment c'était là après cavalier à 5
apparemment il devait jouer qui avait
français 5 et même si l'ordi donné
l'ordi le CC la machin il donnait
également de toute façon lui donnera
toujours 00 mais faut penser 5 puis on
prend qui a validé 7 avec va dans
analyse et 6 on analyser tous ces deux
et tout avait l'air intéressant on a
même analysé fou des deux cavaliers
français 5 et fousser deux qu'on aimait
bien
avec l'idée que si tu joues B3 tu te
prives de la casse B3 avec le cavalier
qu'on peut faire fouter mais après
ramenez le fou en C3 enfin ouais donc
ça nous paraissait tout ça nous
paraissait intéressant il y avait C6
aussi qui était intéressant bon comme je
dis avec un jeu parfait c'était
oui
à chaque fois tu mettais un peu de
pression et il est parti pour cavalier
prend F6 et donc la théorie de Vlad
c'est comme il joue pas les mérrants les
antimerans il a sous-estimé puis on
prend
pas mal de dames prends et des e quattro
avec l'idée de ramener le fond en G5 et
ça se comprend mais il a complètement
sous-estimé l'idée de GF d'après enfin
d'après Vlad on lance
et là tu te retrouves avec un rock
opposé et
c'est peut-être pas si clair c'est
peut-être pas un gros avantage noir ou
quoi que ce soit mais
prend ses cinq
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas qui je sais pas quand tout à
l'heure
qu'en fait tu vois il est juste position
déjà digne mais juste les pages 3 mais
bon
il y a pas longtemps en plus
c'est incroyable
mais bon
comme ça
elle était pas
F6
moi j'ai pas regardé
[Musique]
donc ouais
il y a même quatre H3 on a eu
pas trop été impressionné j'imagine si
c'est très impressionnant très bien joué
très fin mais alors pourquoi
nous on saura pas
faire attention
du coup on va rester sur le direct mais
oui et du coup bah il joue l'accepter
parce que Ben normal
et voilà quoi
pardon c'est pas non non mais ok
des trois bon il menace sous français 4
donc 3 B8 logique et bon là c'est bon
[Musique]
le truc c'est que c'est perdant pour
deux raisons donc les B2 te reprend ses
7 qui prend des un pour ces deux points
[Musique]
tours C8 B3 donc dans ce temps là
ah mais il a oublié ce truc oui mais ça
enfin moi j'avais vu sans en parler qui
prend des deux tours c'est ça qui est le
premier film je me suis dit depuis tout
à l'heure qu'il fallait éviter de se
prendre ça parce que évidemment c'est
fini immédiatement trop de matériel bah
c'est de fou et une tour contre une dame
c'est juste fini donc faut des trois
rois B8 c'est pas faut penser 4 alors
[Musique]
non je pense qu'il impose mentalement
bon déjà hier un peu mais simplement
hier la position elle était peut-être
plus facile pour quelqu'un qui m'a
remarque il était foutu mais
[Musique]
je gère là dans une position tactique si
tu imposes imposes mentalement c'est tu
te fais balayer quoi non plus il est bon
pour le calcul
bah disons si tu fais [__] pour pas
faire faut penser à quatre
mais bon il fait sa tête surprise
il comprend pas quoi
[Musique]
du coup tu me nations profond tu peux
pas prendre ces quatre et la dame a rien
à faire en C2
[Musique]
n'a même pas considéré le coup en fait
non
il a joué mais c'est genre comme si ah
oui bon ça c'est très con ça va c'est
juste qu'il fait n'importe quoi depuis
plusieurs coups donc
[Musique]
il se fait déchirer en fait ok mais bon
peut-être que c'est pas si simple
[Musique]
dommage
c'est facile mais
si tu as papillon prend
ok le meilleur coup pour l'ordi c'est
fou c'est de ouf ou bien
mais sinon
c'est déjà fini peut-être bah c'est
parti là niveau du joueur prépa c'est OK
maximum 2000 hello si ça finit comme ça
pour les blancs c'est juste qu'il peut
pas jouer
submergé par les émotions émotionnelles
c'était quand même moyen mais ça se
comprend enfin je veux dire ça
s'explique ça se comprend non mais c'est
rien contre lui mais c'est que bon c'est
un désavantage que Magnus a eu dans tous
ces matchs en fait car en première fois
mais bon mais les mecs étaient arrivés à
faire mais
on avait discuté avec Van on discuté
aussi avec toi c'est aussi le problème
du fait que tout le chemin qualificatif
pour le match champion du monde ne se
joue oui mais ne se joue pas en match
donc fait les mecs arrivent et non pas
d'expérience en match donc ils sont
aussi faire quoi pénaliser
et là ça se voit pour Ding ce qui joue
pas du tout à son niveau là c'est c'est
mauvais vas-y trouve F5 bah c'est l'idée
fat a mis la tour en G8 pour te mettre
en face du roi et tu as envie d'ouvrir
ton fou sur G2 c'est pas F5 c'est le
coup le plus évident c'est le coup que
tu joues en Bullet en fait si tu
réfléchis pas et qu'on dit juste un coup
et que tu as pas de temps tu fais F5
[Musique]
et le problème pourding c'est que quand
même il fait pas F5 il fait juste un
coup un autre on était déjà bien quoi en
fait
même tour c'est quoi
même juste forcé
8 c'est avantage même tu passes ton tour
même tu fais H6 tu es quand même bien
non mais c'est réel non mais c'est juste
tu passes ton tour tu es encore mieux
mais eux c'était vraiment la case de la
dame
en réalité là
il fallait pas faire tourcer il fallait
faire dame E1 en fait tu protèges le 4
et tu tapes
et sur F5 D5 voilà c'est ça qu'on avait
regardé et tu bloques et quand il te
fait grand rock comme ça tu as [__] en
B4 et tu mets
on discute avec glace c'est pas facile
mais bon
de trouver des trucs comme ça parce
qu'on disait c'est que Damien enfin là
c'était plus moi qui disait Vlad dans
mon ressenti personnel donc moins fort
que Vlad mais c'est quand même tu fais
deux choses tu défends le cadre que tu
as envie de défendre et tu tapes B4 que
tu as envie d'attaquer et du coup
tu fais des choses que tu as envie de
faire et le truc de mettre la tour
ancien et la tour en E1 c'est que bah il
veut ramener le fond et fin en fait
ça va frapper fort ça va frapper dur
le Punto Fab heureusement qu'il a pas
gagné hier ça ferait deux heures ce
serait déjà fin du match OK ou ça serait
notre vie mais
[Musique]
là est-ce que on n'est pas
il faut les Marvel il faut changer il
faut revenir dans le passé pour
le défoncer en fait ça va être dur
tu te fais fermer
c'est trop trou quoi
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
niveau de jeu néant
c'est trop c'est dommage parce que enfin
juste je me repasse un peu la partie
pour bien comprendre comment il s'est
foutu si vite dans la merde perdre en 15
coups
donc H3 ok donc ça c'est obligé de faire
du coup
pour lui
mais ça j'aurais l'impression que ça va
déjà pas trop mal pour les Noirs quand
même non mais ça ça va en fait
A4
de fou le petit fou c'est tout
c'était un peu mieux et tu as aucun
risque après tu vas finir le droit de
bien jouer et te faire nul sans problème
mais ouais et là tout d'un coup ça
dégénéré quoi
GF E4 et il a hésité
quand même
français
deux tu as pas d'autres cases
et du coup madame C7 logique
et là il a implosé en fait à partir de
KFC il y a plus un coup qui va c'est
juste tout est faux
en fait ça va pas très vite
c'est le premier coup qui joue on repart
et j'ai l'impression que deux ce moment
là c'est il y a plus un coup en fait
c'est tu te fais ça peut aller très vite
dans la partie peut durer trois heures
max
ah il se fait il se fait
rouler dessus marcher dessus
après il y a d'autres termes mais qu'on
peut pas forcément dire mais mais qu'on
pense fort
non c'est difficile
l'ordi
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs moi j'ai pas l'ordi mais
il aurait beau dire torcer deux il doit
quand même te dire que sont très très
bien
parce que de -2 quoi
ça va être pire encore
ouais mais
non mais de dépôt il
joue bien quand même ça fait vraiment un
mot qui joue bien au premier match mais
bon la situation inverse de Ding cette
fois là enfin faut s'y mettre ta carte
SCÈNE en face et que la partie moins 2,3
avec CC ouais mais en plus le problème
c'est que c'est moins 2,3 et c'est
difficile à jouer ouais c'est un ordi
qui défend
[Musique]
c'est fou bien pour le coup pour rester
ouais mais bon
c'est juste tu peux pas jouer
physiquement tu peux pas faire pousser
deux [__] des trois fous bien
peut-être tu fais mais tu le fais
perdant quoi
avec les blancs en championnat du monde
mais à égalité au score ça doit être ça
doit bien remonter à quoi que c'était
pas un nom qui s'appelle
déjà même un an Delson je sais pas si ça
n'a jamais gagné Nord je veux dire en
premier avoir une première victoire
noire ah oui ok voilà c'est sûr que Kram
nicanland
première victoire noire de caryatine
avait été assez particulier de cette
partie d'ailleurs mais beaucoup forcée
quand même c'est à force de forcer
c'était fait contrer
on va dire que ça et la partie là elle
ressemble le plus au scénario c'est pour
ça que ça nous est venu en tête de
cramique canon en plus c'est cela aussi
oui c'est le même structure c'est vrai
c'est ça il fait vraiment penser
pour savoir ça ressemble vraiment ouais
dans le scénario dans tout
même chose c'est la même chose en fait
une époque a une le titre est-ce que ça
donne envie à Carlson de revenir pour
bien je pense pas non au contraire ça
confirmerait que
mais
la boîte plus fort moi rien me dit qu'il
organise facilement le deuxième match ah
mais c'est pas sûr
on fait comme si oui c'est vraiment à
rien de venir c'était évident bah
évident de quoi enfin viens jouer je
sais pas quoi dire mais en fait c'est
mon ressenti quoi après c'est aussi
évident qu'une finale de Roland-Garros
Nadal Federer mais on y a toujours cru
pour FEDER mais bon à chaque fois
on se dit bon on va peut-être cette fois
c'est jamais couru d'avance à 100% quoi
tu dis ouais peut-être que
si tient la diagonale Robert
l'agresser sur deuxième balle puis à
chaque fois on y arrive pas
de faire ça il est en cours ouais
c'était clair
je me souviens de genre du dernier tu
vois en 2011
tu vois dans le couloir quoi et si
bon bah il y a qu'un zéro hein mais bon
[Musique]
voilà faut encore le jouer le match
c'est ça que je veux dire donc on est
sûr de rien
j'y arrive pas à ça glisse mal quoi
après il perd toutes les parties et on
sait pas
mais j'y crois
pas que pour Ding dans cette partie
parce que là je crois que la partie elle
est je vois pas enfin si la sauve c'est
incroyable parce que ça me paraît
injouable
c'est trop facile quoi
[Musique]
il a pas trouvé de
pas en plus on sait qui marche à la
confiance qui marche à la forme et que
ça peut ouais ça peut tourner court il
tient courte
9 parties le match
j'espère qu'il vous plaira
moi je suis surtout sur les mots mêlés
très intéressant moi je prends le livre
que pour les mots mêlés
donne-moi des mots mêlés
c'est une sorte de joli Bodin
voilà c'est joli ouais donc bon voilà
déjà donc sur ton front des cartes il y
a pas qu'il y avait les prends
bon le problème c'est que là vous voyez
il y a des problèmes sur la colonne D
et c'est la merde le fou des trois doigt
bouger
tout de suite donc c'est pas une pièce
de la partie semble vraiment enfin on
voit vraiment pas de coup
et
bon du coup c'est quoi la menace des
noirs on peut se demander parce que
peut-être il y a pas une menace direct
c'est juste le problème c'est que si
jamais on prend un 4 sans aucun coup
toute façon stratégiquement c'est
horrible pour les blancs tu trouveras un
pion des 4 isolés il me casse forte en
dessin il y a toutes les pièces actives
donc peut-être ça perd pas en deux coups
mais
mettez juste mal vraiment mal et tu peux
pas trop faire grand-chose
non je sais pas il faut peut-être faire
du coup il va jouer des coups
mais bon
si on prend tout en 4 c'est quoi
l'évolution
pour savoir si tu fais un truc con comme
ça ok
mais bon tu vas pas le faire non non
mais moi je veux pas tout prendre
[Musique]
faut qu'il tente un truc comme ça
peut-être qu'il va se [__] en bécasse
ici
mais tellement mal placé c'est horrible
tout seul non plus
comme ça à mon avis
tu vas dans tes fous prends à 5 d'un
point à 5 et prendre des 4
[Musique]
ah c'est horrible en plus ça te reprend
des cas tu reprends C4 te reprend
un truc bizarre comme ça et espérer
qu'il y a un truc quelque part mais vu
les cookies le truc c'est que vu les
cookies qui vient de jouer si vous
comparer un combat de boxe c'est souvent
ce que disait mon entraîneur Murtas
c'est que là en fait il vient de se
prendre un crochet un uppercut il vient
de tomber 8 secondes par terre et on
regarde des coups il se relève et tout
d'un coup c'est Mike Tyson enfin il faut
se dire que là c'est juste qu'il vient
de se faire
il a pris il est vraiment tombé à terre
et il se relève il attitudant et tu lui
demandes de trouver roi F1 avec qui en
fin de 20 de poser la tour
c'est ouais c'est compliqué
[Musique]
de toute façon au pire tu fais fout ici
quoi
et donc
là tu perds des pièces à droite à gauche
enfin 500 l'air F400 rd300 l'air
non non c'est trop dur enfin
[Musique]
et D5
voilà ça mais je pensais prendre au 4 et
ouais mais ce que je peux tenter
ok ça et ça
et des quatre je peux faire j'ai envie
de faire
[Musique]
un peu mais un grand terrassement qui se
prépare quoi
ouais tu as du RN bien protégé
tu as les Colosso qui sont là
vidéo YouTube ou le gars il estime que
250 colossaux ça suffirait déjà faire un
énorme grand terrassement mais là ils
sont mille fois plus
250 ça suffit quoi
mais bon je trouve un peu con c'est
Colosso enfin il devrait être très très
puissant quoi en échange juste il marche
en fait
mais c'est encore plus beau quelque part
c'est un peu l'équivalent des Titans
débiles des premières saisons quoi ils
sont moins débile mais
bon ils ont peur très très finaux quoi
[Musique]
mais les poissons
pas trop compte après on a du sage c'est
pas où on a ouais bah c'est lui qui a
dit qu'il sentait pas bien maintenant
en fait je veux dire si jamais ça va pas
trop pourquoi faire une telle partie
ah bah oui je sache tout ça
et surtout là il prend ses 5 en soit ça
séché elle pouvait rien t'arriver de
trop grave et prends F6
non mais au pire tu rentres même pas
là-dedans tu joues un peu tu montres un
peu un truc tu fais une de tes catalanes
et tu laisse tes potes séché mais bien
et puis tu répètes et puis c'est tout ah
c'est beau quoi
de caméra du coup j'ai une salle de
repos mais salle de Digne sauf que
personne sur pause
mais on va le voir retourner à la salle
de repos
ils ont juste changé la cam
sûrement parce que l'autre marchait pas
et ça la marche je sais pas ce qu'ils
font
pourquoi c'est un code-barre
c'est ma champion du monde c'est un
moment que ouais
peut-être qu'il manque de temps
[Musique]
non mais je sais pas émotionnellement
c'est pas facile
après ouais bon car on était pas trop
mal rentré dedans
et avant c'était des
je sais pas Carlson avait eu un peu de
mal aussi pour son premier match le
nombre d’avoir déconner
[Musique]
bon après il était chaud mais
c'était sûrement possible de frapper
dans une de ces quatre parties enfin de
faire plus que ce qu'il faisait quoi
dans combien de coup le rajout de temps
22 coups
ouais ouais bah j'ai envie de dire le
temps c'est pas son problème numéro là
mais ça va revenir peut-être mais bon
c'est la salle de repos de ne pas
apparemment
chez Ding quoi
là c'est la partie elle est partie pour
pour finir rapidement ça devrait
parce que ce matin on disait toutes les
parties ça va faire 5 heures de moyenne
mais en réalité si le scénario c'est
comment cette 1 0 2 0 pour dépôt
mais en fait je m'attendais vraiment pas
à ça parce qu'en fait bon ok j'ai pas
suivi à fond mais moi je m'étais raté
vers quel lieu 4
ça a duré
j'arrive
il y a déjà plus rien à voir quoi
il doit pas être bien comme disait
Maxime dans le chat ça peut libérer même
si j'y crois pas trop personnellement de
perdre
ça peut toujours mais ouais pareil j'y
crois pas trop là du coup
ça peut aussi te mettre un coup au moral
et que ce soit encore pire
après c'est vrai que regarde au
candidats il avait très mal commencé
puis finalement après il a commencé à
bien jouer donc on peut jamais savoir
mais
qui quoi qu'il en soit qui guérisse ce
truc de mal commencé
mais il a que depuis le covid oui oui
bah oui enfin il n'est pas connu pour ça
mais
[Musique]
quoi il est pas assez chaud il voyage la
veille il est pas là enfin qui trouve
parce qu'au pire bah viens cinq jours
avant enfin ou un mois avant non mais je
disais
après bon là le manque de pratique bon
ça il peut rien ils l'ont fermé ils
l'ont fermé mais
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est sûr qu'il a il a rien
vu de la partie enfin j'ai repart là il
est comme dans un aquarium
je pense que s'il te dit les lignes
qu'il a calculé ça va être kata
non mais je ressens
et du coup tu es dedans parce que quand
même tu essayes mais que de toute façon
ça serait mieux en fait de enfin voilà
j'aurais mieux
dans la semoule
quand ça arrive c'est horrible et tu le
sais en plus ah tu le sais c'est
horrible
ça pour le savoir tu le sais
tu prends que des mauvaises décisions
c'est une horreur
[Musique]
inconsciemment c'est dur à expliquer
[__] les coups de merde je pense que
tu peux pas c'est comme si le cerveau il
était éteint quoi tu peux vraiment pas
du monde
pas tant que ça non mais j'arrive bien
avant quoi après peut-être que
aujourd'hui il y a une tellement de
préparations théoriques que ça te
flingue le cerveau
avant tu arrives le cerveau flingué
c'est peut-être plus dur à cause de ça
c'est-à-dire pour ça que Manu s'est
arrêté aussi
mais c'est peut-être trop parce que la
phase de préparation est tellement dense
[Musique]
et
et puis il vient nous filmer les
sponsors et je sais pas une coupe un
truc
flou en plus
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est incroyable ce qu'il arrive
tous c'est bon
[Musique]
non ok belle preuve de lucidité
d'accepter son erreur mais du coup c'est
trop grave quoi
en fait
[Musique]
tu peux pas prendre ses quatre mais le
truc c'est quand n'est pas Ferrari
j'habite je tourne donc ouais c'est F5
qui l'a pas vu je pense
j'ai que ça comme explication
il a eu une absence
non mais le problème de position tendue
comme ça c'est que bien sûr une erreur
elle coûte cher quoi
c'est pas
[Musique]
0,20 quoi
après ouais c'est pas le coup numéro 1
que l'on pense mais bon oui pour passer
la dame pourquoi pas mais il y a
peut-être d'autres coups
OK
[Musique]
fermer la case B3
et tu as plus besoin de détendre
ok ici ça semble assez logique
c'est pas ok
bon même faut ça
et peut-être essayer d'envoyer un dessin
que là quelque part
tu as un truc comme ça un peu
ouais ouais ça devrait pas suffire mais
bon prolon enfin ça dépend surtout une
époque maintenant en fait
si il trouve des bons coups il va
mais je pense que tu dois y aller
chercher un truc comme ça pour lui
fermer les diagonales si tu peux
la position est difficile en tout cas
ouais c'est et donc FC coup numéro 1 de
l'ordi parce que tu viens jouer pour
dame G7 et t'empêche tu fouger 5 mais je
sais pas pourquoi c'est pas
c'est pas classique comme coup entre
guillemets
si ça paraît quand même plus logique
puis tu le ramènes maintenant il fait
plus rien là-bas mais c'est pas un
coussin mais bon après bon et si tu peux
quand même trouver peut-être
c'est horrible il y a rien qui va mais
ça force quand même de sa force
trouver des coups quoi oui il faut finir
ouais
il y a des -3 donc on disait pas
n'importe quoi
je crois c'est le coup le plus logique
et donc là faut G5 c'est le coup le plus
logique aussi et là d'après l'ordi pour
vraiment terminer il faut trouver tout
reprend mais c'est trouvable mais c'est
tropable cavalier prend et qui allait
prendre des quatre
damage 5 normal ouais on se barre
qui sait au moins tu as un avantage
matériel avec les Blancs
tu mets la focale là dessus
tu ne sors pensé 4
tu NASDA me prend F7 mais je sais pas ce
que c'est si évident quand tu joues ce
que tu te dis pas d'avoir un truc comme
ça
donc on se dit oui
quand même
[Rires]
c'est pas si clair que
mais bon
C4 tu reprends H7
mais va donc du coup ça prouve que sur
l'écologie qu'en fait tout d'un coup
un truc qui peut se passer un truc qui
peut se passer
mais ça aussi c'est théorème de Murtas
quand tu es moins bien si tu peux
choisir une variante ou tu as un
avantage matériel c'est pas mal quand tu
es foutu comme ça parce que au moins
l'autre s'il sera en fait juste il perd
quoi c'est du même pression s'allumer
une pression
mais ok maintenant si je défends je
gagne en fait tu ok mur tu passes quoi
ouais t'es pas bien tu te rends des
ouais tu te prends des théories de
Murtas dans la tronche tu peux tu peux
te retrouver mal
donc je pense fouger 5 d'un point de vue
pratique c'est ni le Cool 1 ni le coup
de dos de l'ordi
mais je pense que d'un point de vue
pratique c'est gênant parce que si c'est
que ton projet 5 et prends G5
et des cadres je sais enfin j'ai
l'impression que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi Vlad est je sais pas
s'il va devenir s'exprimer je pense vous
avez pas d'accord mais ça moi je suis
pas sûr que je suis gagnant avec les
Noirs je suis peut-être très con
tu es d'accord
ne gagne pas ce que tu joues bah ouais
enfin je sais pas que c'est noir est-ce
que tu rentres là-dedans
le Vlad
non il faut qu'il fasse je suis sûr
qu'il faut qu'il fasse bouger 5 du coup
je suis certain que c'est fou j'ai 5
pour pour avoir une chance
et comment les Noirs écrasent si je vois
et il commence par B3 admettons
et pourquoi il est rajouté
donc tranquille
à tout à l'heure déjà on avait du roi F1
quelque part
on va réessayer pourquoi il fait ça
quand même
ok là c'est moins clair
que ce qu'on regarde depuis tout à
l'heure
ok c'est pas complètement fini
mais qui est certes
mais quel mauvaise série cool à Tours
c'est un fou des trois tours
[Musique]
en fait là il a juste pété un plomb il
n'a pas compris
et comme ça à partir de coller ici rien
compris mais je veux dire tu vois ici là
de faire foudre
parce que c'est ça bon il vient son roi
il fait ça tempo ça il réfléchit à fond
et il fait ça on a regarde la caméra qui
a pris sur des pots en train d'enlever
sa ceinture
après un coup comme fougère ils ont
prises quoi
et il va ce qu'il pense à ton frangin
donc voilà on voit là avec cette caméra
on voit comment il réfléchissent
maintenant
je pense pas
mais ça aurait été beau qu'il fasse mais
c'est pour frapper le gosse
d'après l'ordi qui est fort mais bon
tour des 7 c'est quand même une
concession
parce que peut-être un jour quand tu
fais des dessins ou quoi tu auras des tu
sais tu te rappelles dans les variantes
qu'on regardait
un moment donné quand tu prends H7 en
plus tu reviens enfin
il faut ça
c'était quoi c'était [__]
quand même des temps parce que ça veut
venir tu veux venir en F4 sur échec donc
admettons d'âme des 6 moins bon pourquoi
pas
bon ça a quand même l'A4 mais en réalité
je suppose et tu protèges le cap de par
le clouage
[Musique]
il a pas de bol n'est pas
parce que ça aurait dû être beaucoup
plus facile après des coups telles que
fous des trois et pousser deux
c'est intéressant pour moi de comprendre
pourquoi est-ce que tout je sens qu'au
lieu sans que les deux cadres
j'ai pas compris pourquoi est-ce que
c'est si évident que ça gagne
il te fait le F6 qui est proche
mais là c'est cavalier F5 seul coup
unico
il va pas il va pas faire
ah il a pas de bonne
parce que ça ça aurait dû écraser
intéressant
je pense que l'oiseau
moi c'est le coup que je
ferai moi quoi
tu commences à perdre 2 3 tempo comme ça
si tu dois faire mater en ligne et là
c'est pas le cas mais bravo à Digne pour
le pousser de c'est dur hein
d'avoir trouvé ça très haut niveau de
jeu en fait il a fait n'importe quoi il
fallait il a joué 2000 hello pendant 5
six coups et là faut C2 c'est 3200
on fait quoi est-ce qu'on se ferait pas
la pause maintenant avant le direct note
bah si vous voulez on peut se faire une
petite pause petite respiration on
respire tout le monde respire après ce
fouger 5 n'est pour va réfléchir un
moment parce que le coup le coup fait
mal et on se retrouve
dans une petite dizaine de minutes à
tout de suite l'élite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs tous les coups ont
été trouvés tous les coups donnés par
dans le live ont été trouvés par dépôt
il a pris G5 prix G5 et prend des quatre
damage 5 comme prévu F6 et là il a pas
pris H7
j'avais pas non plus mais qui était le
coup le plus challengeant il est revenu
en F3 et donc après qu'elle prend ses
deux tours français de et fou prend le 4
bah j'ai envie de dire comme prévu la
position va s'écrouler bah le problème
c'est qu'il y a déjà pas d'autres termes
matériels vu qu'il a deux pions pour la
qualité tu as la paire de foot tu as
l'attaque tu as les cases tu as les
pions qui avance
est-ce qu'il y a tout c'est que même
sans ça c'est déjà très bien quoi après
dommage de pas avoir fait qu'il prend H7
qui semblait être le coup qui
challengeait le plus quand même
qu'est-ce que
bon il y a aussi des problèmes je veux
dire mais
fuite évidemment c'est quand même moins
pire et fou c'est 5 foodé un
[Musique]
matériel
le match champion du monde qui pourrait
tourner court
pas trop mal
parce qu'après c'est trop on aura des
gain de temps
tu vas voir des fois H2 un jour et tu
reprends des deux
tu m'as déjà [__]
des deux d'ailleurs donc tu vas devoir
jouer quoi tourner
[Musique]
c'est vraiment c'est devenu facile et il
y a pas qu'un cookie
non non non
tu avais encore un espoir il y a que le
qu'il faut avoir le cahier des 5 machin
il aurait eu mais
c'est pas sûr là ouais la foudre - 7
c'est normal parce que c'est terminé
partie qui tourne court
c'est logique dans le sens où tant de
ces rapports là on veut pas échanger
et en plus
ça crée
c'est pas qu'un coup qui empêche son
c'est que tu menaces de gagner une tour
ce que la prépa était n'était pas
mauvaise un moment mais trop tard
il a joué trois bons coups
j'ai 5 mais oui c'était déjà fait
mondial ça avec un y
c'est le i c'est le i
c'est le N
ici et gagnant c'est
14h c'est spectaculaire
carrément
mais en fait combien de temps
je veux dire
j'espère pour lui qu'il va se dire
c'est fait c'est fait et
j'espère qu'il va se ressaisir ouais
avec avec les Noirs déjà bien tenir
parce que deux points d'écart après tu
commences à suer quand même bah c'est
dur il est dur
donc
déjà qu'on pensait qu'il était favori
avant maintenant qu'il mène à zéro vu le
contenu des deux parties
bon ça fait beaucoup
comme on l'a on vient de le montrer en
fait on vient de l'expliquer déjà trois
quatre fois c'est pas que c'est simple
c'est que c'est évident
on est peut-être à libérer de façon il
peut pas faire pire donc tranquille
ouais c'est ce qu'on disait mais pour la
dans le dernier match quand il a perdu
contre carlsheim ça va être le libérer
bon j'étais très libérée pour donner des
pièces on a quoi donc
à voir ça peut aussi le faire
complètement impoli surtout que dans son
équipe avec rapport qui l'accompagne qui
est pas le gars le plus stable
psychologiquement du circuit
ça peut tourner court
il faudra Amazon dans l'équipe pour
Amazon
[Musique]
c'était trop facile sinon
Ding avait aussi perdu contre des pots
au début des candidats mais c'est encore
un autre problème supplémentaire
Théodore c'est que dingue il réussit pas
bien jouer contre nepo donc déjà c'est
un matchup qui est difficile tu es
stressé le mec te battre un moment donné
ça peut
puis en fait c'est pas content d'avoir
que des trucs négatifs tu joues toujours
contre le même sens une différence par
rapport au tournant au moins bon j'ai un
grand pas de compte lui mais ça va
j'aimerais faire sur sur les autres
là c'est lui qui revient encore et
toujours tous les jours quoi
c'est dur
tu as un joueur qui te réussit pas
tu rejoins
juste pour vous dire on nous a dit c'est
pour ça en fait ils ont changé la caméra
de repos et on l'a eu parce qu'en fait
les joueurs ont demandé à ce qu'on ne
montre plus les caméras de repos
ou la fille ou quelqu'un en tout cas
et donc
justement c'est pour l'enlever ils l'ont
changé d'adresse sauf qu'ils ont mis sur
une adresse d'une autre caméra pas de
chance du coup on a eu par hasard
mais juste vous débranchez qu'en fait
il voulait pas qu'on ait du coup ils
l'ont débranché ils l'ont mis sur
l'adresse
de la tournée justement spectaculaire
mais dans quoi il est joueur veulent pas
être filmés dans la salle de repos ce
que je peux comprendre donc ça veut dire
que le match en fait tu vois vraiment
jamais les joueurs c'est
est-ce qu'il y a des spectateurs je
crois qu'il y en a quasiment pas
enfin d'habitude les salles sont
ouvertes au public normalement il y a
une vitre un truc pour pour ça
tu es pas là en mode
de toute façon je sais pas trop qui va
aller voir
il y a pas grand chose à voir en fait
non
en tout cas bien joué
après oui sur le début de match qui soit
devant
ça pourrait vraiment faire de zéro là
enfin bon après on sait pas comment
serait passé cette partie etc mais je
leur parle ah oui c'est juste que dit
que là il arrive pas à jouer un coup il
est dépassé par l'événement
je sais pas comment dire
c'est que digne avant 2020 c'était
clairement le numéro de mondial mais pas
trop loin de carpent d'ailleurs
il avait gagné
que
il était là
bon covid et je sais pas il arrive plus
depuis
il est qualifié grâce à un fils de
procédure c'est candidats donner la
deuxième place qualificative machin
c'est enfin il y a rien qui va cette
fois
je sais pas qui doit être là en fait
pour moi un épaule va gagner point final
en fait et comme karpone 75 en fait mais
bon voilà c'est ça c'est donc là en fait
je suis pas mais c'est juste visé de lui
j'aimerais bien qu'il retrouve ses
esprits tout court
échecs quoi
il a une
peut-être qu'il y a une très belle vie
en dehors des échecs que ça se passe
très bien pour lui et bon ça fait
peut-être pas du tout hein peut-être
qu'il a trouvé l'amour pendant le covid
non mais non mais c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
enfin bien jouer avec la partie 3 et
peut-être besoin de
quelques rondes de quelques coups
donc jouer la digne mais il y a plus de
coup quoi il essaye
de trouver une défense quelque chose
c'est ça le problème
je pense qu'il va abandonner rapidement
il est passé à travers
mais il a pas l'air bien quand même
non
il comprend qu'il a quand même fait un
peu n'importe quoi
en fait vous dites tout ça mais vous
dites à chaque fois que il parle ça
peut-être le réveiller le premier 7 6 0
bon je me réveiller oui bon enfin
[Musique]
moi je vois pas de positif à cette
partie normalement fait déglinguer comme
ça sur deux parties que tu es content de
tourner un ennemi Denis
après c'est possible mais c'est quand
même pas le scénario favori
le décomplex est mais pourquoi tu serais
décomplexé en fait le mec te convient
pas c'est quelqu'un qui te bat très
souvent et ton machucha théorie vous
allez voir comment ça recommence et il
te défonce encore plus gravement que
d'habitude tu es pas en train de te dire
je suis décomplexé enfin tu dis
deux jeux blancs d'affilée au service de
0,4
je suis bien quoi je vais mettre des aïs
globalement ça ressemble au match
précédent dans enfin dans l'autre sens
avec cette fois-ci nepo dans dans le
rôle du prédateur après voilà enfin il y
a un monde où ça libère et où il gagne
une partie et où le cours du match
change tout d'un coup mais pour le
moment
pas trop pour le moment pas trop
mais on se rappelle d'Ali resa aussi qui
avait mal commencé et ça pas ça va pas
trop libéré non
dur tu as besoin de confiance donc quand
tu as pas de confiance c'est d'autant
plus dur de jouer et là il vient de
jouer deux parties où il passe à travers
quand même et donc quand tu vas devoir
lâcher les coups dans la partie suivante
tu joues un peu avec la peur au ventre
avec l'impression que tu vois rien et tu
as pas confiance tu regardes
tu fais ce qu'il faut pas faire quoi
et c'est normal de le faire parce que tu
ouais c'est dur
tu as besoin de confiance dans tous les
gens en général je pense ouais mais aux
échecs
et c'est pas facile de la récupérer
non non
c'est difficile
non mais je veux dire j'en sais rien je
vais te prendre un truc débile mais tu
vas comprendre dans genre au foot ok si
tu as plutôt confiance dans ta technique
devant les cages ou quoi bon c'est
chiant c'était un vrai mais tu peux
faire d'autres efforts pour l'équipe tu
retournes repris défensive tu fais
d'autres choses ou tu es utile mais
voilà là déjà parce que c'est à calculer
que tu sais que tu arrives pas
tu vas faire plus du tout enfin tu
deviens d'un coup une grosse base de
niveau là en fait si tu craques devant
les cages peut-être tu changes un peu de
rôle enfin ok c'était moins bien
et peut-être petit à petit ça revient là
surtout en longue en blitz tu peux
encore rejouer des parties tranquilles
faire des NU enfin mais là en longue
c'est dur
le même te remplacer au foot oui bien
sûr
individuel en général la confiance c'est
quand même plus difficile à reprendre
c'est comme au tennis quand tu commences
à tout sortir mais tu as des joueurs qui
réussissent à bien se remettre mais
vraiment c'est une finale Championnat du
Monde c'est tu joues pas contre le
techno du coin enfin c'est toujours
contre top top mondial et c'est dur non
mais oui pas mal de tennis mais genre
pendant team
[Musique]
on se défaites d'affilée là enfin quand
tu commences à perdre c'est dur mais en
plus c'est dur parce que c'est pas comme
team ou tu te retapes sur de la TP 2050
si tu viens de perdre contre Djoko et tu
retrouves encore et tous les jours
je sais pas tu as envie de jouer du
munar quoi
sur dur tu es en plus hein
je vais reprendre confiance
Goran il va dit tu vas te mettre en
confiance au retour
ouais c'est difficile
voilà plus de 300050 mais il a pas de
coup et il va abandonner
parti avec qui va durer trois heures et
demie croyable
perdre avec les Blancs
de manière aussi sévère
comment tu abandonne si il y a personne
bonne question
tu abandonnes
ouais
[Musique]
ouais ouais non ouais c'est parti
tu peux te laisser tomber aussi ouais
mais là maintenant vu comment il est
parti il peut aussi c'est aussi une
option
[Musique]
c'est possible
mais ça fait des
vingtaine d'années que j'ai pas vu ça
quoi
c'est rare
rocher
là ça va être C3
un truc comme ça on nous propose
beaucoup
pareil
non non bien sûr
S
[Musique]
je pense peut gagner bon après le truc
c'est faudrait gagner avec une tour de
plus bon ce serait pas facile mais là
des pots qui va prendre le temps pour
revenir
mais non c'est
mieux je suis pas sur la non mais
peut-être 1000 vous gagnez pas mais non
mais en fait l'enchaînement de pousser
le pion
vous avez enfin
et puis tu pousses ces deux dame
[Musique]
de pions
en fait
c'est trop facile
là c'est trop facile
il tourne la bouche et que j'ai
l'impression qu'il parle et c'est deux
hein
piège avec les blancs en fait ça va être
la difficulté avec les noirs
même pas
est-ce que X 3 il y a un problème pour
avoir Fiat enfin juste
non plus donc oui
parce que des fois tu dis un truc comme
ça est-ce que sur la vente principale et
un piège en fait c'était tellement
désespéré que tu peux même pas et il est
chaos là en fait il est il y a pas 30
secondes par coup si je crois qu'il y a
30 secondes ah bon c'est pas deux heures
trente secondes
commençait pour finir
[Musique]
donc ils ont changé je pense la dernière
fois c'était pas KO
il y a tellement de cadences différentes
mais ils changent
mais pour faire plus ou moins la même
chose à partir du 60e c'est ça
change absolument rien
reste assis une minute
ça change pas grand chose
débile de partir ouais c'est un peu
ouais mais bon comme vous avez compris
les joueurs restent jamais assis en face
de l'autre ça se donnerait de belles
images vas-y là il va vraiment
abandonner alors que l'autre est debout
toute la matériellement il va même plus
avoir le temps de finir
physiquement
pas de piège
4 est-ce que après tout reprend des
supers
tu peux lui faire en espérant le faire
tomber
pas de chance
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va pas se relever de
toute façon
pas assez de temps pour Ding
il me semble que c'est enferme la tour 5
il va faire tourner deux selon ferme à
moitié quand même
peu importe il va se relever 100 % la
réalité c'est ce qu'il a le temps de se
relever parce que digne il va devoir
jouer en moins de 10 secondes
ah il est concentré quand même il a
raison il faut bien être sûr
qu'il a pas l'air bien non il est
désabusé je pense de ça
ça fait mal
il continue à noter il abandonne c'est
terminé les amis victoire de Yann
nepomiashi dans cette deuxième partie
qui aurait été dominée de la tête et des
épaules et du bide surtout du bide bravo
bravo à lui on va vous préparer le petit
le petit résumé de la partie comme
d'habitude pour que vous puissiez revoir
ce qui s'est passé et les
erreurs de Ding qui l'ont mené jusqu'à
cette catastrophe industrielle on vous
remercie d'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas que
demain c'est le jour de repos mais on
devrait quand même avoir du backi pour
le title alors là d'autant plus
intéressant et on sera de retour pour
mercredi les commentaires
du Championnat du Monde mercredi matin
11h et ce soir si j'en ai le goût je
ferai peut-être une petite session de
participer pédagogique 500 550 donc là
pour les débutants attention on suit ont
su ont su pour
arriver au mille et l'eau merci à tous
encore une fois merci Fab et un petit
coucou à Vlad qui doit nous regarder
bonne soupe bonne soupe bonne soupe à
toi et on se retrouve donc mercredi pour
la suite de ce match en espérant avoir
un Ding de meilleure facture au revoir